if you got is not quite working
optimally even though you might not have
any specific symptoms it can still have
an impact on your mental health and your
mental performance when people are busy
and they're working too hard and they're
doing a side hustle and everything else
is high pressure people tend to make
their diet quite small so they might end
up eating the same types of foods on
repeat and inevitably those ways of
eating have an impact on your gut health
whether you feel it in your gut or not
this episode is an interview with one of
the UK's leading experts on gut health
her name is Sophie Medlin and she is a
dietitian she's also the chair of the
British dietetic Association for London
and she works as a lecturer at King's
College London and is actually also on
TV these days as an expert for channels
4 show which is all about the science of
the gut anyway I learned so much in this
episode and you're going to learn so
much as well about the gut and about
Healthy nutrition and about what are all
the myths around things like seed oils
and should you eat carbs and is fried
food bad for you and what are the things
that we can do to help improve our gut
health and how the gut brain access
works and how like our gut health
contributes to all of the other aspects
of our life inevitably if it's not happy
it's going to be screaming at your brain
or the time and that is noisy and
difficult for your brain to cope with
and that can lead to things like brain
fog and struggling with focus and
concentration for example similarly if
your gut isn't happy but you don't
really know from other symptoms but
you're getting loads of bugs infections
viruses all the time you notice you're
really susceptible that's a good time to
start looking at your gut health and I
think I guess for this audience what's
really important to recognize is this
connection between your gut and your
brain and how they are constantly
communicating with each other for better
or worse at the moment according to the
YouTube analytics 81 of you who are
watching this on YouTube have not yet
hit the Subscribe button and so if
you're for example in the now 81 of
people who are watching this on YouTube
but who are not subscribed to the
channel I would love it if you could do
so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun Sophie thank you so much
for joining us thank you for having me
you're an expert on gut health I am yeah
I'm the Poo expert the Poo expert yeah
and you've been on TV talking about poo
and I would love to talk about poo and
everything about the gut but I guess as
a starting point how did how did we get
here how did you come to become the gut
expert what's kind of a blitz of your
life story yeah great question so I was
a weird 15 year old child that knew I
wanted to be a dietitian so I was very
lucky to kind of have this direction
from a very young age I was studying
catering at GCSE and I had a catering
teacher who was a nutritionist and we
did some stuff on like celiac disease
and adapting diets a little bit and I
thought yeah I think that's something I
might like to do so I did a little bit
of reading and thought well I could be a
nutritionist which is a bit quicker to
train to do but that won't necessarily
open up all the doors to me and then I
read about being a dietitian knowing
that I could then go and work in the NHS
and do all sorts of other things within
the world of nutrition I thought well I
might as well keep all the doors open
and at this point I was predicted D's
and E's and using My GCSE so I thought
I'd do some work and make sure I get the
grades I need to get into University but
it's really really good motivator and I
managed to turn that all around and get
got good enough grades to get in and
yeah studied nutrition and dietetics and
the story starts from there most
dietitians start working in the NHS and
that's what I did so I was in the NHS
for about eight years I did some
interesting stuff in elderly medicine
where you get really good at kind of
understanding about nutrition support
which is basically supporting under
nutrition so malnutrition
doing lots of tube feeding making
difficult decisions about whether people
should be tube fed or whether that's the
best thing for them or not given it
might be the end of their life that sort
of thing
um I then did head and neck cancer where
you look after people who have all kinds
of horrific tumors in their mouth and
their throat in all sorts of different
places where obviously eating is
massively compromised and at that same
time I was doing a split roll with
intestinal failure and then I went on to
do a full-time intestinal failure role
where I was you know just super inspired
by amazing colorectal surgeons doing
incredible things amazing specialist
nurses stoma nurses people who were just
turning people's lives around and people
who are in their most sort of vulnerable
moments of their life
um and nutrition has a massive impact on
what comes out your bottom right what
you put in the top end has an impact on
what comes at the bottom and when you've
had any kind of bowel surgery or you are
suffering in terms of your digestion
what you put in has a huge impact not
only on your nutritional status but also
on your on your quality of life so your
experience of eating so if you eat the
wrong things and inverted commas you're
going to be potentially incontinent and
having all sorts of terrible problems
that really affect your quality of life
and make your life very small
and when I was able to see what a
massive difference I could make in that
environment a people's quality of life
to their experience of living to their
experience of eating their relationship
with food I was like this is what I want
to do forever so I I've stuck with that
very much in terms of my clinical
expertise I uh was then a lecturer and
researcher for five years most recently
at King's College in London and at that
time I was struggling a bit with kind of
I love Academia I love teaching I love
working with students makes me really
happy I love that kind of mentoring
aspect of it but I was struggling with
some of the kind of
things that other people found easy the
admin side of things timetabling that
kind of thing things that might seem
like they don't really matter because
you should have admin support but you
just don't in those kinds of
environments and it's things that you
know upset the students because they
don't necessarily know where they're
supposed to be and so I was talking to
my mentor and she was saying look you
know if you were a student we'd say to
you why didn't you get tested for like
dyslexia and other conditions like that
and I thought well that's probably a
good idea so I got tested and I found
out that I've got dyslexia dyspraxia and
ADHD so full hat-trick and at this point
in my life I was trying to make a
decision as to whether I wanted to
pursue a bit more private practice and
see more patients which I'd continue to
do through my academic practice and
maybe do some TV work which I'd started
to do a bit of and work with the media a
bit more and do some consultancy or
whether to do my PhD
and getting that diagnosis made me
realize that actually I could torture
myself for three years and four years
trying to do my PhD or I could make this
decision to focus on the things that I'm
naturally good at the things I'm don't
find so challenging the things that come
to me easily rather than trying to push
in a Direction that's always going to be
a difficulty for me so that's what I did
I quit my job at Kings which was a
massive deal set up the business it kind
of a couple of years before that I did
two both at the same time for a long
time which was far too much
um but yeah I've been running my clinic
business called City dietitians for
about four years now
um outside of kings and I've got a team
of 10 or 11 maybe even 12 dietitians now
with our own Specialties I also run a
consultancy company where we design
vitamins and probiotic products for
different companies and yeah I do some
TV Work Media work things like this
fantastic that's like the most coherent
kind of answer to that question I've
ever heard
you've clearly had practice in front of
a camera
um what is a dietitian yeah great
question lovely place to start so a
dietitian is like them we're like the
Medical Nutrition people is what I would
usually say so if you have a medical
problem that you want advice on in terms
of your diet you need a dietitian only
dietitian in the UK you wouldn't want to
see a nutritionist for that
nutritionists aren't medically trained
you wouldn't want to see a nutritional
therapist they're much more on the
alternative therapy Spectrum
so dietitians are the Medical Nutrition
people we're the only people who are
allowed to work in hospitals in the NHS
that kind of stuff
nutritionists are basically there to
help healthy people get healthier so
they're amazing at Public Health
incredible at research but really
important to remember that anyone can
call themselves a nutritionist so in
this country term nutritionist isn't
regulated which means that there are
some people who have just done a quick
you know 30 pound nutritionist I don't
know training course online and now are
calling themselves nutritionist you have
to be a little bit careful with the
credentials of a nutritionist that
you're taking advice from but that
doesn't mean to say there aren't
incredible nutritionists out there doing
amazing work in lots of different areas
so I don't mean to diminish them as
colleagues they just do a different job
to us yeah and so what sort of Medical
Training do you have as a dietitian a
bit like if you think about a
physiotherapist you would say okay so
physiotherapist is different to like a
massage therapist or a sports therapist
they're qualified people who've gone in
and done placements in hospitals and
worked alongside doctors and nurses to
learn their trade that's the same as
dietitians so we do three long
placements as part of our University
training uh where we go into hospitals
and learn from other dietitians on the
job and when we are registered with the
hdpc the healthcare professions agency
and they help us to regulate everything
that we do so if I do something wrong
I'm accountable and I can lose my
registration like a doctor or a nurse
could unlike other people within their
profession sort of the nutrition
profession at large where there's no
accountability so they could say
anything at all and something could go
really wrong and it's not their fault
because there's no one regulating them
nice
yeah I think nutrition is one of those
things where occasionally people ask me
hey you know you're a doctor therefore
like what should I do about XY I'd be
like that sounds like nutrition we had
like two lectures on it yeah and the
start of first year no one cared about
it ever since then and the only contact
I had with dietitians was
oh we're we're feeding this patient
through a tube let's call The dietitian
and then get them to do some alchemy and
tell us what for me to prescribe yeah
um or there would often be Cardiac
Arrest calls downstairs to the
dietitians because a lot of them would
faint in the morning
um so I'm really unfamiliar with the
nutrition side of I guess medicine and
life and also with I guess the job of a
dietitian but I guess I'm you know for
for people listening to this who maybe
do not have officially diagnosed
colorectal problems or bowel problems or
stomas or things like that what does a
dietitian do for a I guess normal
healthy person so dietitians don't get
involved very much with normal healthy
people we're mostly dealing with disease
or problems so most of my patients would
have a problem with their bowel it might
not be like a diagnosed thing they might
say I get this really unpleasant wind
and it's really bothering me and we can
work on that but generally people will
have a problem before they come and see
me in my kind of public facing work I
guess we're talking about gut health
education and trying to get people to
look after their guts so that we don't
end up in the situation where they're in
my clinic with a physical problem with
their bowel or in surgery because of a
physical problem with their bowel so
that's where we talk about how we can
really optimize gut health not only for
our bowel Health let's call it but also
for our general health because our gut
has a massive impact on our mental
health and on our physical health and
our risk of loads of different diseases
and disorders and actually the one we
look at gut health the more we realize
that it isn't impacting every part of
our body and every system in our body
how did how does gut health impact all
the like the the the thing that's always
struck me whenever I've listened to
podcasts where where they're talking
about the gut is that it seems like the
gut is kind of this sort of Black Box we
don't quite know what's going on but we
know that it impacts literally
everything uh I wonder if you can kind
of break up in that black box a bit to
what extent does the gut impact all
these things that you've talked about
yeah I'd love to let's talk about that
so obviously on a very basic level your
gut is where all of your nutrition is
absorbed and every bit of your body is
physically made from the foods that
you're eating so if you imagine your
skin is made from proteins and lipids
that come from your diet the things that
you're consuming you're basically just a
big walking blob of protein with other
bits and pieces floating around in there
so actually everything that we eat has
an impact on the structure and function
of the whole of our body so if your gut
in terms of its General function isn't
great then we can have real big problems
and these are kind of things for
potentially even things like gallstones
which are Super common other bits and
pieces generally just not consuming a
very balanced diet so then you've got
has to work harder for various different
things we're using different parts ways
so having a healthy gut is super
important to the structure and function
of the whole of your body and how it's
working but that's mainly we're talking
about kind of the first bit of the small
bowel so about the first bit of the Bell
which is a small vowel which is meters
and meters and meters long travels into
the colon and in the colon you've got
like this amazing ecosystem of bacteria
and other microorganisms that are
constantly communicating with the rest
of our body and this is the bit that we
really have been learning more and more
about over the last kind of 30 years or
so but it's really common to the four
now how are microbiome so the the
bacteria that live in our colon are
interacting with the rest of our body
and how that works is that when we eat
various different foods so let's take
plant fiber as an example you eat some
fruits and vegetables they travel the
bits of it that you can't digest the
bits we can't break down travel through
to our colon where they're fermented by
different species of bacteria and yeasts
and other types of microorganisms and in
that fermentation process they produce
some gas and they produce other things
but they put really importantly produce
some metabolites some things that
interact with our bodies so things like
short chain fatty acids for example
butyrate is the sort of strongest
research example that we have when
butyrate is released by probiotic
bacteria in the colon that travels
through into the rest of our bloodstream
and interacts with the rest of our body
it helps to control inflammation we've
seen incredible work with butyrate
production being controlling of the
inflammatory Cascades associated with
covert for example so butyrates
controlling inflammation in the body
other metabolites interact with our
immune system so 70 of our immune cells
live in our small in our bowel in our
colon and your gut bacteria are
constantly interacting with them and we
also produce 95 of the body's serotonin
in the gut which links to our brain
health our mental health and how we're
feeling so your gut is constantly
interacting with the rest of your body
and it's physically chemically and
hormonally connected to all the other
systems in your body wow that's a lot
going on do any patients come to mind or
have you seen any stories where
someone has had like quite bad gut
health and then it's been transformed
into good good gut health and then their
whole life has changed like I wonder if
you can kind of paint paint one of those
pictures for us oh my God yeah every
week in clinic it's transformative for
people and you know we've been lucky
enough to Showcase some of that on the
recent Channel 4 show that I've been on
which I'm sure we'll talk about later
but just uh if you imagine somebody who
cannot control their stools so their gut
health and potentially their rectal
muscles for example are badly damaged by
maybe childbirth or just by the aging
process and so everything that they put
in the top end they're constantly
fearing having incontinence fecal
incontinence in a supermarket on the bus
wherever they go and to be clear with
you this isn't just old people this
happens to young people people of all
ages and stages of their life can
experience this for all sorts of
different reasons I think that's
probably the biggest example of where
what I do as a dietitian can make the
biggest difference because if we can
help someone to control their bowels so
they're no longer fearing having an
accident that obviously has a huge
impact on their of life it's not just
things like that you know we can get
people out of pain through adjusting
their diet if you've got kind of
problems with the structure of your
bowel something like diverticular
disease for example which is super
common condition unfortunately it
creates problems with the structure of
the bowel and that can create a great
deal of pain when you're eating
particular Foods so we can adjust the
diet and get people out of physical pain
and often when I'm working with patients
who have things like inflammatory bowel
disease
I'll say to them look I can't cure your
IBD I can't cure your Crohn's disease or
your ulcerative colitis but I can
probably help you to get out of pain and
reduce the symptoms and for them that's
perfect that's all they're asking for
they're not looking to me to try and fix
the problem they just want some symptom
management that they're not necessarily
getting medically and yeah those are the
sorts of things that we deal with every
week in clinic and I guess IBS is
probably the biggest one that we see a
lot of and that is less debilitating for
some people but for some people it's
incredibly debilitating with really
painful bloating and and gas and things
like that which they find very difficult
yeah okay so let's say let's say
someone's listening first and they're
thinking Hmm maybe I have a problem with
my gut but I'm not really like what what
are the sorts of signs and symptoms that
someone who doesn't is not is not
diagnosed with like inflammatory bowel
disease or something might have to make
them think huh maybe I should see a
dietitian yeah great question so I would
say what's helpful is to start with
what's normal because we don't talk
about poo right so people don't know
what's normal and what we found in
General is kind of actually people just
might live with symptoms that they don't
actually have to live with but they just
get used to them partly because they're
embarrassed to talk to anyone about it
but also they've never checked what's
normal so in terms of normal bowel
function we would say that anything
between so passing stall anything
between three times a day and three
times a week is normal if that changes
for you so for example you start off
being a three times a day person and
suddenly you're a three times a week
person that's when you need to get some
help something's not quite right there
so we call that a change in bowel habit
and I'm not talking about having
diarrhea occasionally because you've
eaten something the night before or had
too much to drink I'm talking about it
being consistent so over about a two
week period if you notice your battle
habits change significantly for you
that's the time to go and get some help
this consistency of your stool is the
next thing to think about so what we're
looking for is kind of like a smooth
sausage-shaped poo that holds together
when it goes into the toilet itself
so most of the time that's kind of what
we want most people will be somewhere
either under that Spectrum fluctuating
between the two so sometimes it's too
hard sometimes it's too soft and that's
okay as long as kind of your median your
medium range is kind of in that soft
sausage snake-like poo territory
um and then we think about kind of wider
symptoms beyond that so things like
urgency for example if you notice that
you when you need a poo you really have
to rush and you are worried about that
and it comes on very suddenly for
example that's when you could get some
help if you find that your poo is really
hard and difficult to pass and you're
feeling uncomfortable or you're
developing hemorrhoids or piles or
you're getting anal fissure so like
tears in the bottom those are things
that we could help people with for sure
and then if you think the color of your
poo might be a bit funny it's an
interesting thing to talk about but the
color of your poo needs to be like a
medium brown color is normal
occasionally you might eat loads of
sweet potato and it might be a bit more
orange or you might have a green
smoothie and it might be a bit more
green that's fine but as an average if
it's kind of a medium brown color that's
great and we don't want it to actually
be ridiculously smelly so if your poo is
like really foul smelling we would think
that maybe you're not absorbing
everything from your food and that's
something to look at or you might have a
really affected microbiome that needs
some work if you've got loads of gas
that's really uncomfortable for you and
or it's particularly smelly that's a
time that we can do some things to make
that better for you we've got any
abdominal pain at all really important
time to get some help even if it's that
kind of pain that you're thinking
I know it comes and goes I think it's
probably okay definitely go and chat to
somebody about that because there's
things that we can do to make it better
so in terms of normal and things you
could get help with I think that kind of
covers the basics of of what people
might be living with and just putting up
with that actually they could get some
help with and that are probably signs
that something's not quite right in
terms of their gut health
as you were describing the snake-like
snake uh sausage consistency I was
thinking that my poo was often a lot
softer than that until I started taking
the heights Prebiotic probiotics that
tablet thing yeah and now I'm always
surprised that like oh this looks like a
normal poo it looks like what I think a
normal Perth um so that's been nice
um
what if someone
feels like they their poo is normal
based on all these kind of parameters
that we've talked about
is there any reason for someone with
normal poo to be thinking about their
like diet and nutrition in that sense
like are there other optimizations that
healthy people without gut problems can
make to improve like productivity
performance that kind of thing yeah for
sure so if you've got is not quite
working optimally then that can even
though you might not have any specific
symptoms it can still have an impact on
your mental health and your mental
performance right so your gut is such an
integral part of your whole body system
and ecosystem and inevitably if it's not
happy it's going to be screaming at your
brain all the time and that is noisy and
difficult for your brain to cope with
and that could lead to things like brain
fog and struggling with focus and
concentration for example similarly if
your gut isn't happy but you don't
really know from other symptoms but
you're getting loads of bugs infections
viruses all the time you notice you're
really susceptible that's a good time to
start looking at your gut health and I
think I guess for this audience what's
really important to recognize is this
connection between your gut and your
brain and how they are constantly
communicating with each other for better
or worse so there is a very strong line
of communication between your gut and
your brain which we refer to as the gut
brain axis and again they are chemically
connected through neurotransmitters that
are produced in the gut they are
hormonally connected by the HPA axis and
they are physically connected by the
vagus nerve and the chattiest organ
between your brain and your gut is your
gut your gut is constantly telling your
brain all sorts of different things and
throwing messages up that it's got to
deal with and people might think oh it's
your brain you've got it's not really
doing anything but actually your brain
is busy and it's communicating and it's
a lot through those microbes that live
in your colon
sick
you're very good at this thanks it's not
my first time you've got the whole like
wow
[Music]
um so what can I do for example as a
proxy for people listening to this
my poo is fine once a day you know
medium brown color not overly smelly I
think but everyone like the smell of the
red poo apparently
um but
obviously I want to kind of maximize my
performance and my focus and actually
one question we we get so often from our
audience is people struggling to focus
and I think often people are like I
struggle to focus with my schoolwork or
with my whatever web design side hustle
I must have ADHD as like an immediate
option but I wonder if there's gut stuff
we can do before we get to that point
yeah definitely I mean your gut health
is so because your gut is constantly
communicating with your brain again if
your gut is not happy things are
communicating differently but also you
could just not be producing enough
serotonin for various different reasons
or your gut might not be sending the
right signals up to your brain so you
might have if we looked at your
microbiome and it's certainly not
necessary to do that we can do this in
clinic without testing but if we looked
at your microbiome we might find that
you've just not got enough of these
bacteria that are doing this particular
important job with brain connection
stuff
um so what we would suggest then is to
really optimize the gut and you know
what happens Ali as you know is when
people are busy and they're working too
hard and they're doing a side hustle and
everything else is high pressure or
they've got a family and everything else
people tend to make their a diet quite
small in not necessarily in terms of
volume but the types of foods that
they're eating so they might end up
eating the same types of foods on repeat
what I see is people as kind of two
camps here the people who do like the
meal prep stuff and they eat the same
Foods five days a week and they think
they're being super healthy eating sweet
potato and broccoli every day or you
have the people who are just living meal
to meal prep you know Etsy wherever
they're going every day the same sorts
of things but just various different
places and nothing's particularly
planned or thought through and
inevitably both of those ways of eating
have an impact on your gut health
whether you feel it in your gut or not
so that way of eating limits the types
of fibers that you'll get bacteria being
fed and the most important thing for
your gut health is that you're eating 30
different plants a week so trying to eat
loads of variety of different types of
plants that includes fruit and veg but
also nuts and whole grains different
types of grains we're super fixated in
this country on like oats and wheat but
actually there's so many different types
of grains that our guttery benefits from
so when you're busy and you're
struggling and you're eating meal to
meal or you're eating the same Foods on
repeat what happens is you've got Health
you've got sort of function might not
change but your gut health is inevitably
not optimized and that's when you can
have these problems with lack of
concentration Focus energy getting bugs
all the time that kind of stuff and
really interestingly your gut bacteria
communicate with your hypothalamus so
that bit of your brain that controls
things like cortisol production so
really early in your life your gut
bacteria dictate where your sort of HPA
axis is set so how much core style you
release in under given circumstances and
we all need some cortisol right but we
don't want loads and loads of cortisol
because we've got loads of anxiety and
stress all the time we can really
struggle to concentrate and to focus so
we can use our gut bacteria to try and
reduce that and make things a little bit
better in that department we can use
them and harness their powers to get
more serotonin which helps us with
better sleep and concentration and focus
and all those important things those
happy hormones and we can also just try
and calm down those messages from our
gut to our brain which are distracting
our brain all the time and your gut
bacteria are going to be saying we need
more plants and you're going to be not
reading that properly and giving them
more Sushi and that's not quite what
they want wow so
it sounds like you're saying please
correct me if this is an
oversimplification that changing up what
you eat can have a massive impact on
your Focus productivity performance
happiness absolutely because all of
those things are linked gut brain
everything yeah fundamentally I mean and
proven in amazing research in science
yeah what kind of research has been done
on this I guess I'm I'm thinking healthy
people rather than people with official
gut problems yeah so uh the amazing work
of John cryen is a really good place to
to start looking at this stuff if people
are interested and he's written an
amazing book called The psychobiotic
Revolution so psychobiotics are these
gut bacteria that communicate with our
brain so they're the ones that we're
particularly interested in when we
develop the height smart probiotic for
example so work that's been done in that
area to start within rodent models they
used a model of an autistic mouse and a
model of a non-autistic mouse or
sociable Mouse and they took the
microbiome so they took a sample and and
gave the microbiome of the autistic
Mouse to the sociable Mouse and the
sociable Mouse starts to show autistic
traits okay and when they swap them over
the autistic Mouse starts to become a
sociable Mouse just because it's got
microbiomass changed yeah so that was
the early work that they did trying to
understand how much our gut microbiome
is impacted impacting our mental health
our mental performance how our brain is
working so similar studies to that have
then been replicated in humans in other
places and to be clear that autistic
Spectrum Disorder stuff in humans is so
complex and we can't replicate that
exactly in humans as yet but there's
certainly something going on there which
is what we generally learn from rodent
studies we've also got some great data
showing things like increase in
production of Serotonin when we use
particular probiotic species there's
great data showing that using particular
probiotic species within treatment diets
and things like that so within treatment
within studies in controlled studies
improves anxiety depression all of these
kinds of symptoms and wider nutrients
within this world if we think about
things like Omega-3s and B vitamins
they've been used in place of anxiety
and depression medications ssris that
kind of stuff and they work as
effectively in some people some of the
time in study so we can use all of these
things and a similar work has been done
with the two straight one two of the
strains we use in the smart probiotic in
terms of seeing whether they work as
effectively as common anti-depression
anti-anxiety medications and they do so
much so that there's Health claims on
them in Canada that people can say these
are definitely shown to improve anxiety
and depression
so there's great data it's a young field
of research but it's super exciting and
it's very solid research just showing
that the magic that we can harness from
our gut
nice
sweet so clearly there's a lot going on
uh one of the things you said um nice
actionable takeaway for me and anyone
listening to this 30 different plants a
week I know that's a lot it sounds like
a lot but actually if you break it down
into days you're looking for about five
different plants a day so what you would
say is like for example for breakfast if
you had like a multi-grain cereal or a
whole grain cereal you're gonna have
loads of different in there in there
Chuck some seeds in Chuck some nuts in
Chuck some dried fruit and I love
freeze-dried berries amazing Chuck some
of that stuff in and actually you're
kind of already there with at least five
different plants in there then at lunch
time maybe between your lunch and your
breakfast you could have a handful of
nuts there lunch time make sure you're
having at least a couple of different
veg in there maybe Chuck some seeds on
top and then in the afternoon you want
to have some fruit as a snack and in the
evening make sure you're having some veg
like actually if you spread it out like
that it's totally achievable for people
unless you're doing one of these funny
restrictive diets that you know nobody
would recommend anyway all right we're
just going to take a quick break from
the podcast to introduce our sponsor
which is very excitingly heal I have
been a pain customer of huel since 2017
so it's been about six years now that
I've been using Hill fairly regularly I
started eating Hill in my fifth year of
medical school and I've been using heel
regularly ever since because you know I
like to be productive I've you know my
calendar is full with a lot of things
and often I don't have the time or don't
make the time to have a particularly
healthy breakfast or a particularly
healthy lunch my favorite flavor is
salted caramel because 400 calories you
get 40 grams of protein which is
absolutely insane and you also get a
decent healthy mix of carbohydrates and
fiber and fat along with 26 different
vitamins and minerals which are all very
good for the body there's nine different
flavors of this to choose from my
favorite is a the banana version and
also the Salted Caramel version so what
I do is I take my two scoops I put them
into my NutriBullet blender type thing
although you can just use a normal
Shaker if you want I mix it up normally
with water but a little bit of milk to
add a bit more of a milkshake like
consistency to it and then I just sip
that while I'm on my desk doing my work
in the morning and it ensures that I get
a very healthy breakfast in that's
nutritionally complete rather than some
high sugar cereal which is what I would
have defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to 20 000
pounds and it resets every April and
then all that money can grow and it's
completely tax-free for the rest of your
life and if you want to sign up for an
iso you can sign up for one completely
for free also on trading 212. so if you
haven't yet filled up your eyes
allowance or at least put some money
into your Isa for this year that might
be a good step forward the app also lets
you Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading
212 into your respective App Store so
thank you so much trading 212 for
sponsoring this episode yeah at the
moment I'm trying to do a sort of high
protein low calorie thing to cut with my
health coach and all this kind of stuff
but you know his thing is like you know
at least for a while let's just try and
eat the same thing every day broadly so
that you know what's coming into your
body and then we can see how that
affects your weight all that kind of
stuff I mean you can see me cringing
right absolutely terrible advice so I
literally I've got some content planned
for this week around what terrible
advice I see from personal trainers and
I'm sure your guy knows what he's doing
in terms of personal training but the
worst things that personal trainers do
there's three things I see them doing
regularly for people one is putting them
on the same Foods on repeat because
you're starving off your essential gut
bacteria and some of those really
important gut bacteria are actually
protecting you from obesity so they're
working to help you to control your body
weight and so if you're starving them
you're making your life much more
difficult in the long run secondly it's
like this really low fiber diet
typically and so that's just as a
measure of them cutting out
carbohydrates nobody's look to check
because they don't know what they don't
know right no one's checked that there's
at least 30 grams of fiber in there
which is what we all need every day for
healthy for healthy stores and a healthy
bowel usually they're around 16 grams of
fiber when we calculate them it's just
half of what we need and then the other
thing is having loads of red meat or
loads of animal products generally so
the world cancer research fund says we
should only have three portions of red
meat per week and that's 500 grams 350
to 500 grams in total otherwise we're
putting ourselves
not every day no about 350 to 500 grams
total a week otherwise we're putting
ourselves at higher risk of bowel cancer
and so again these meal plans that
people are given actually are starving
your gut bacteria which puts you at risk
of loads of different problems putting
you at higher risk of things like cancer
which nobody wants and all kinds of
other things but it's it's not the fault
or the personal trainer it's but going
circling back to this conversation of
nutrition for people in the nutrition
space giving advice on things they just
shouldn't really be giving advice on
right so if you want nutrition advice
and tailored specific nutrition advice
for you you need to see we've got an
amazing Sports dietitian on the team at
City dietitians who can tailor all these
things for you and give you a proper
tailored plan that note that you can
actually manage in terms of everything
as opposed to just thinking about that
one thing which is the Aesthetics which
everyone gets fixated on oh that's handy
I'll book an appointment with that'll be
good
30 grams of fiber what does 30 grams of
fiber look like in a diet well it's
about half of what the average person is
getting oh sorry it's about double what
the average person is getting so most
people in England eat less than half of
what they actually need in terms of
fiber every day so most people are
getting around 15 grams of fiber a day
so we need to make sure we're adding
lots of extra things in things have
happened within the social media space
that have made that happen so for
example people now demonize breakfast
cereals where actually loads of us got
loads of fiber from breakfast cereals
every day women were mainly dependent on
breakfast cereals for iron for a long
time and slightly different now but
actually we cut these things out because
an influencer tells us to and actually
there's consequences for everything that
we move around in our diet right so
thinking about where your sources of
fiber are so we're talking about whole
grains fruits and vegetables nuts and
seeds that kind of stuff where are your
sources of those in your diet and could
you maximize them so for example
swapping white rice for whole grain rice
is a really great step in the right
direction white rice for whole grain
pasta if you're having like mince for
example so minced beef add some lentils
in there just bulking up the fiber a
little bit leave the skin on your
vegetables on root vegetables that kind
of stuff leave the skin on get a bit
more fiber there make sure you snack on
fruit those kinds of things it's
basically the stuff that your mum would
have told you to do when you're a kid
it's all that stuff we need to do to try
and boost our fiber intake and most
people just aren't getting enough what
to do with breakfast cereal my in in my
influencer adult understanding is
breakfast cereal is bad because lots of
sugar and American advertising companies
convinced us that breakfast was the most
important meal of the day that's BS we
should all be intermittent fasting and
just skipping breakfast in the morning
anyway because 68 fasting is good for
you so therefore breakfast cereal is
evil yeah sure yeah I mean I hear all
those things as well I think the key
thing with breakfast cereal is it can
very easily become what we might call an
ultra processed food and that's where
it's just got loads of extra additives
in it that you wouldn't recognize in
your kitchen preservatives emulsify as
that kind of stuff lots of extra sugar
salt all those kinds of things so we
want to avoid those ones so the ones
that look like they're super commercial
will probably want to push them out the
window but you can add things in in
terms of making your own sort of
breakfast so you can toast them out just
toast some stuff to make granola that
kind of stuff some of the more natural
granolas would be a good choice for you
but in terms of fasting there's no
evidence of any benefits of fasting
Beyond weight control so there is some
reasonable data to show that fasting can
improve weight control but also there's
this count interacting data coming
through now where people who don't eat
enough in the morning and tend to
overcompensate and eat much more in the
evening and that's worse for us from a
metabolic perspective we've kind of got
this biological night of around 9pm
where all of our processing of
everything slows right down so things
can sit around in our bloodstream a lot
longer and cause more trouble if we're
eating too late at night so actually if
you're someone who wakes up hungry and
you're dragging yourself through till 12
o'clock into your eating window and
you're feeling terribly got headaches
and you feel awful that's obviously not
the right way for you to be eating your
body and we're all different from a
circadian rhythm perspective right our
body clock is all different so if you're
someone who feels hungry in the morning
you should eat in the morning just
listen to your body be a normal person
if you are someone who just doesn't feel
very hungry at night you might find it
easier to finish eating at six o'clock
and that might work really well for you
but really importantly if you're trying
intermittent fasting and you notice that
you're really loading those calories
later in the day it's probably not right
for you most studies will show that
actually if you have some calories in
the morning and front load your calories
a little bit you'll reduce your calories
later in the day which is metabolically
a bit better for us what about things
like chicken and fish what are like
how much chicken and fish should I be
eating so your body your breath your
bowel doesn't particularly like red meat
it certainly doesn't like processed meat
so the the data on process meat says
little if any processed meat for
protection of bowel cancer so process
might be things like sausages bacon even
things like cured meats that kind of
stuff is just not great for our bowel
health and any animal meat any animal
proteins our body our bowel can quickly
find that too much so a good example
that people might recognize is if you
ate like a meat Feast pizza or like had
a massively heavy meaty meal usually
your gas the next day or later that
evening is going to be pretty foul
smelling and that's because when we have
too much animal protein in particular
it's then some of that leftover protein
that we can't absorb and digest is being
fermented by really bad types of
bacteria they're really not good guys
that we don't want to be feeding and
when they ferment stuff they release
methane and sulfur and these bad
smelling gases so if you're having
really fast smelling wind the chances
are you might be over feeding those guys
that don't you don't want to be feeding
them too much so we can help to balance
that out clinically and in with
treatment
um so excess protein from any Source
excess animal protein from any source is
not ideal for people so your gut health
your gut bacteria also really like plant
protein so things like soya and tofu
that kind of thing so ultimately it's
about getting that balance right and if
you're someone who is having meat for
lunch like twice a day you're probably
having too much meat hmm now okay
um how
how do I get my protein if not from meat
great question so you can use plant
sources of protein so like tofu soy and
products that kind of stuff and
obviously we want it to also not be
ultra processed so I'm not talking about
that beyond meat burger or that highly
processed vegan product what I'm talking
about is adding tofu to your stir fry
for example using the minimally
processed soya mince in place of beef
mince for example still great sources of
protein for you and absolutely no harm
eggs are slightly less dramatic in terms
of your bowel function than uh meat is
so a bit easier for you to digest and
fish is even better so if you're having
fish regularly that's great for you in
terms of protein Source also great for
your brain lots of benefits having fish
a bit more regularly than meat what are
the benefits of fish
which is magical
all kind of evolved to need a lot of
fish in our diet and in England we just
like nobody eats the two portions of
oily fish a week that was recommended
right if we did the supermarkets would
be sold out tomorrow we need two portion
of oily fish a week for our brain health
it's really really important for
controlling inflammation in the brain
the structure of your brain my very
clever colleague Kimberly Wilson says
that if you take out if you don't eat
oily fish it's a bit like taking out 25
of the bricks of your house and
replacing them with polystyrene 25 of
your brain wants to be made from oily
fish right so if you take it out of your
diet it's a bit like replacing 25 of the
bricks in your house with polystyrene it
kind of looks the same structurally but
under a strong wind you can have a real
problem and it's very much the same with
our brain health so you really want to
make sure you're getting at least two
portions of oily fish a week or taking
in omega-3 supplement if you're a vegan
that could come from an algae oil source
and that's equally as good in terms of
our brain function but also your gut
bacteria love Omega-3s so it's really
good for helping to promote the
populations of beneficial bacteria that
helps control inflammation the body all
that kind of stuff so omega-3 from fish
is super super important for our bodies
but it's also a great source of lean
protein
what do we mean by oily fish so oily
fish is like the ones that taste a bit
more fishy but salmon is a great example
that people find really accessible so
that's good but also mackerel is perfect
we could use sardines that kind of stuff
the ones that are in tins they're a bit
more fishy there's a lot of people
benefit from the most tender tuna no
unfortunately not an oily fish oh I know
that's annoying and that's what we all
eat right yeah okay so salmon twice a
week would be good for me perfect
fantastic I like salmon salmon is tasty
um
to what extent can I just be like you
know what
I accept all this stuff but I can't be
asked to change my diet too much if I
just take the appropriate number of
supplements I'm good right
yeah no it doesn't really well
unfortunately so we need to think of
supplements as being like the icing on
the cake right so we still need to do
the foundational work if those if we
want those supplements to be working for
us so it doesn't matter how many pills
you pop ultimately if your diet is
terrible you're really stressed all the
time you're not looking after your
mental health you're not exercising
you're not looking after your body
you're still going to struggle you're
still going to suffer so you need to be
doing some of those foundational things
and then taking your supplements on top
to try and get things in line and with
probiotics that's even more important
because you can take as many probiotic
bacterias you like in capsule form or as
kefir or however you want to but if
you're not feeding them with plant fiber
when they get to your colon they're not
going to survive there's nothing there
for them to eat so we have to make sure
that we feed them when they get there
some people will put prebiotics or food
for good bacteria in their supplements
but actually need quite a lot of that
Prebiotic fiber to make any difference
and actually the best way of getting
that Prebiotic fiber is from your food
from the food that you're eating so it's
really important to encourage people to
still maintain a healthy diet and look
after the other things
um because we need to do all the things
unfortunately nice okay so
less than well 500 grams red meat per
week preferably two percent 500 grams
yeah 350 to 500. you've got that down
okay down yep I'm like
it's like a single stake it's like I
love that
um 30 grams of fiber a day which most of
us are not getting so we need to add
more seeds grains whole grains yep fruit
veg that has like texture and stuff to
it because that's fiber two portions of
oily fish a week adding adding in soy
mints and tofu and to replace animal
products sometimes yeah anything else
what are some other yeah I guess gut
bacteria does not like processed food so
we think that things like oh well if you
imagine preservatives that are put in
processed food are there to to make sure
bacteria doesn't grow you can then
extrapolate that and think okay well
what's that doing in my body so when I'm
consuming these foods with preservatives
actually are they killing off my good
bacteria or at least stopping them from
growing so that's something to think
about emulsifiers that are in lots of
processed foods and also in lots of
foods that I've got a bit of a health
Halo like protein shakes and protein
products that kind of stuff emulsifiers
we think are disrupting the lining of
people's bowels so when we have too much
of those kinds of things that tight
junctions between the cells in your
bowel wall we think are being disrupted
and opening up a little bit allowing too
much inflammation into the body and
causing all kinds of different problems
but also disrupting that really
important mucosal layer in the bowel
that is the home for our good bacteria
so emulsifier is not great they're in
plant milks and stuff like that so we
keep a little out for those
um anything that is kind of an added
ingredient that you don't recognize is
something that we want to be a little
bit careful of and there's this amazing
data now about Ultra processed foods and
how much they are impacting our risk of
cancers and all kinds of other
conditions so an ultra processed food is
something that we do want to consider
trying to avoid again lots of vegan
products would end up in the ultra
processed food category even though
they've got this health Halo so we need
to watch out of ultra processed foods
defined by all of these ingredients that
you don't recognize we want to think
about
um you got back to just don't like them
for lots of different reasons but that's
part of it processed Meats in particular
gut bacteria I really don't like those
when we're stressed I'm really anxious
all the time we produce more stomach
acid we produce more enzymes things
happen differently in our gut lots of
people will recognize that when they're
stressed they maybe have diarrhea or
wind or they're bloated or they're
uncomfortable and so that's because when
you're stressed your structure and
function of your gut changes slightly
and everything is more difficult but
also when it's a more acidic environment
that changes the pH of the gut when the
pH of the gut is changed that has an
impact on which bacteria can Thrive and
survive and ultimately if you've got too
much stomach acid and there's two it's
too much of a acidic environment you're
going to develop more of the gut
bacteria that are associated with more
stress more information worse Health
outcomes
so Stress Management
careful with ultra processed foods and
processed food in general and also drink
enough water but bacteria really like
should be very well hydrated so there's
things that you can do as well as adding
things in just to be a little bit wary
of but one of the nice things about gut
health is really I'm talking to people
adding things in what more do you need
to take in as opposed to taking things
away which is kind of what Ultra like
Diet culture is all about right so it's
about mostly about adding things in and
ultimately what we see from the data is
when people add more plants in it
displaces some of these less healthy
things in their diet anyway so if you're
snacking on nuts and fruit you're not
going to be snacking so much on on you
know protein bars and stuff like that so
that helps people to move into these
healthier patterns anyway
love it um does tea coffee count as
hydration or does it have to be like
water water so tea is quite good for
hydration and coffee and tea both
contains something called polyphenols
which will get bacteria love polyphenols
are these kind of plant compounds that
are in all different plants and really
importantly and interestingly the
different colored plants all have
different polyphenols in so like the
purple ones are great for your brain
health and the orange and yellow ones
are great for controlling inflammation
and diabetes and stuff like that so they
all have slightly different jobs in our
bodies anti and coffee contain important
polyphenols that are really healthy and
helpful for us but coffee you lose a bit
of hydration every time you drink a
coffee so it kind of has a net negative
effect in terms of your overall
hydration and that's because it's a
diuretic same as tea so it makes you wee
more and you lose more water and then
you end up not as well hydrated so what
I recommend to all my patients is that
while they're making a cup of tea or
they're making a coffee just drink a
small glass of water on the side and
then you know that you've got enough
going in and also just trying to make
sure people are drinking water through
the day
right so the 300 mils of
fluid in this I'm net like less than
that well because the data is not quite
perfect but I would say you're probably
only getting maybe about 25 mils from
that really something like that yeah
damn okay I should drink more water you
should cool real [__]
um what how how do I know if a food is
processed what are some rules of thumb I
mean essentially if it comes in a packet
if it's been through a factory and it's
come in a packet it's going to be
processed by sometimes sausages
um any kind of like ready meal type
stuff
has lots of white bread that would for
General breads that would fall into that
Ultra process category because to make
bread you need flour and you need yeast
and you need salt and you need water but
the ingredients list on some of the
breads that you might pick up on the
supermarket shelf is going to be so long
and so complicated and have all kinds of
preservatives and emulsifiers and stuff
like that in it that actually ends up
being an ultra processed food and we're
in a difficult time alley because people
are struggling right it's a financial
crisis people are struggling to eat
anything at all so it's really important
that we are careful about not demonizing
food Staples that people can't afford if
you're living in a food living off food
from a food bank and all you can get
your hands on is baked beans and Ultra
processed bread and cereal you've got to
eat it right I don't want anyone to take
away from this that it's so harmful for
the health they should go hungry that's
not the case at all we're talking really
here about refining Health as opposed to
people who are struggling right so there
are Ultra processities that we need to
be careful of and we need to look at
those labels it's about those long
ingredients lists with emulsifiers
things that have got a code like
colorings e-numbers that kind of stuff
those are the sorts of things to look
out for and that would be your your clue
that that's an ultra processed food nice
so let's say you and I go to a local I
don't know grilled chicken shop after
this and we get and we're going to get a
takeaway
or just in general when I went out at a
restaurant what are some good rules of
thumbs for what people should order or
should avoid ordering I like I think if
you're eating out unless you're eating
out every day or super super regularly
you should enjoy it right it's an
important thing to so to be able to eat
socially and to be relaxed when you're
eating and not to worry about it too
much but the same kinds of rules would
apply so try to eat as many plants as
you can even if that means ordering an
extra side of broccoli or spinach or
whatever it is on the side of what
you're having we know that frying
potatoes for example has an impact on
our health in general so fried potato
products are not great for us so try to
limit those a little bit I mean chips
are literally my favorite thing so
trying to limit those a little bit is
helpful and important for people so just
sort of thinking especially if you're
eating out really regularly where are my
sources of vegetables here am I getting
enough am I getting some lean protein
and trying to kind of piece things
together in your mind about what's going
on in like on a if you zoom out of your
diet a little bit what have I had to eat
today what do I need more of what do I
not need so much of is helpful
but if you're eating out you should
enjoy it and have a nice time nice
um what's the deal with organic food
yeah I mean nothing really it's just
really a marketing term so
there's no great data to suggest that
eating an organic diet is going to have
any significant health benefits for you
the pesticides and stuff that are used
in the food chain now are very carefully
researched there's very little data to
show there's anything that might do you
any harm what is potentially more
interesting in that field which isn't
really talked about is that when soil
has been really heavily commercially
farmed it becomes less rich in nutrients
than your fruit and vegetables can
become less rich in nutrients whereas if
we scale that down to kind of buying
locally so from your local farmers
market for example less heavily you know
farmed land more nutrients in soil more
nutrients in your fruits and vegetables
so by and also food miles so any food
that's been through various different
lorries and everything else or airplanes
to get to your plate that's going to
have a depletion of those nutrients over
time so if you can buy local as much as
you can that's much more relevant really
to our nutritional status than buying
organic necessarily is oh nice
um what's the deal with uh diet cook and
other non-sugar zero sugar about lots of
artificial sweetener type drinks yeah
you've got bacteria don't like
artificial sweeteners unfortunately
um you know they're they're safe from
like a cancer perspective and all that
kind of stuff there's not so much don't
worry too much about that kind of hype
but what we do know is that when we have
artificial sweeteners our body is
anticipating having sugar and things
change to get ready to have that sugar
and when it doesn't come that has an
impact so there's data to suggest that
it increases our insulin production for
example which makes us also really
ultimately a bit hungrier and can have
an impact on our General Health as well
so ideally sweeteners need to go in
there no thank you bucket as well which
is difficult for people right because
you know when people are trying to get
off sugar sweeteners seem to be a good
thing and to be clear if you're someone
who is having loads of sugar right now
you're better off having some sweeteners
and trying to wean yourself down a
little bit rather than kind of trying to
go cold turkey which will ultimately
probably fail when I speak to people who
have lots of Diet Coke in their diet or
diet drinks in general I generally say
all right let's swap one that's doing
like an alternate thing so if you're
having four a day at the moment let's go
for like swap one for like a sparkling
water then have one next time then have
a sparkling also have another one and
just try to reduce it slightly rather
than taking them away altogether
what's a deal with fruit juices so fruit
juice can have some benefits right it's
got loads of vitamins and minerals in it
and stuff like that so some useful stuff
but also it's a still like a slightly
processed food and that means that our
body handles it differently to how it
would handle the whole fruit for example
so if you eat you'd struggle to eat like
five oranges but you could have a glass
of orange juice even quite a small one
that's got the juice from five oranges
in it so this actually ends up being
quite a lot of fructose the fruit sugar
there and it's just a bit more difficult
for our body to process it then we just
end up having a bit more of a blood
sugar Spike and that kind of stuff that
we don't really want to be encouraging
so a small glass of fruit juice every
day is great we're talking about
something like 150 ml but most people
are chugging like a big bottle of fruit
juice and that can end up being just
just more sugar than you want to be
consuming in one go basically
um is tomato juice special
so there's some interesting data around
lycopene from Tomatoes which is a
polyphenol and it's protection against
things like prostate cancer for example
in men so there's some benefits that
kind of stuff like opinions also really
good for your eyes and other organs in
your body and of course tomatoes have a
lot less sugar in them than oranges or
apples or whatever other sort of juice
you might have so again a small just
glass of tomato juice would be good
you're still better off eating the
tomatoes themselves because you've got
all the fiber and all the other benefits
then I'm I'm just gonna throw some bait
at you because all that all the
healthcare bananas are bad because they
don't have fiber bananas are great for
you this is a there's a medical
conference a few years ago where and
it's famed now where there's all this
sort of really famed like low carb
Community there and we can talk a bit
more about low carb and whites but
dangerous but like the low carbo
community of demonized bananas and there
was a medical conference with proper
doctors and everyone booed a banana when
someone said and then I ate a banana and
this is what it's just my blood sugars
everyone in the audience booed they
booed a banana this is how messed up
this whole world has become like this
wild to me if yeah you know let's say
five years ago I could at least we could
all just at least agree that everyone
needs to eat more fruits and vegetables
and now the low carbers and the
carnivores have come along and even when
I say you just need to eat more
vegetables but those people are like no
no not true you shouldn't be ignition
being that nonsense more plants the
better nice the [__] because I love
bananas and I've been being like oh
banana bad because carbon no fiber no
you're all good
um low carb what's going on there just
starving off your colonic friends I see
lots and lots of patients in clinic who
have had who've been on a ketogenic diet
and inverted commas or been on a very
low carbohydrate diet and ended up with
really terrible IBS ended up with
horrendous piles because they were so
constipated ends up with all kinds of
trouble and the whole grains that we
need to eat in order for our gut
bacteria to be as healthy as possible
come from all sorts of different sources
of whole grains and so when we cut out
carbs altogether we're not having any
grains whatsoever in our diet and then
we're starving off like really crucial
species of probiotic bacteria that do
these amazing things in our body that
we've talked about before so when you go
on a low carb diet you're starving off
some of your really important friends in
your colon you're not feeding them and
that leads to all kinds of trouble
including overpopulation of negative
types of bacteria which have negative
consequences on our health so eating a
wide variety of foods in including
grains and pulses and all that kind of
stuff is really really important for our
overall health and particular of our
health
so if I am trying to
if I'm trying to get shredded and you
know keep the protein fairly High reduce
the calories
um my tactics so far has been avoid
anything that remotely looks like a
co-op unless a friend has got chips
because it doesn't count if I still if
you you know a few of theirs it sounds
like you're suggesting the carbohydrates
are evil approach is kind of bad and
instead I should be like maybe I'll have
a little bit less rice than I normally
would but I've still got that in my
system yeah it totally all have whole
grain rice because you could just can't
physically eat as much of it so whole
grain carbohydrates keep us full for a
long time like protein does so when
we're trying to manage our weight
satiety being full is really really
important so having higher protein diet
good having higher whole grains really
good for maintaining satiety keeping you
full between meals Stopping You snacking
and when people move to like having a
small piece of fish and then loads of
green veg just starving all the time
like it's miserable and it's not good
for you ultimately so let's try and
balance that out a little bit get some
whole grain carbohydrates in there and
I'm not talking about you going and
eating a massive bowl of white rice or
having I don't know a massive bowl of
pasta we're talking about having
introducing some more whole grain
carbohydrates in your diet to feed your
friends keep me Fuller for longer and to
try to manage your weight in the way
that you want it to be managed all right
we're going to take a very quick break
from this episode to introduce our
sponsor which is brilliant.org I've been
using brilliant for the last several
years and they're a fantastic online
platform for courses in maths and
science and computer science brilliant
is a fantastic resource for anyone who
wants to develop new skills but
especially if you work or you want to
work in a STEM related field it's an
absolute no-brainer for being able to
level up your knowledge of these topics
brilliant has an enormous library of
courses that cover all sorts of topics
and the courses are particularly good
because they take a very first
principles approach to the topic that
they're trying to teach like it's not
just that they spoon feed you
information and expect you to memorize
it like often we were taught in school
but it's more like they teach you a
principle and then you apply it with
some interactive puzzle or game or
activity of some sort and then you teach
you a little bit more and then you apply
a little bit more and it turns into this
really interesting kind of engaging
teaching system which is actually
similar to the way that we were taught
at Cambridge when I was in med school
there where you learn a little bit and
then you apply it and then you learn a
bit more and you're generally paired
with an expert in the field and you kind
of learn together and figure it out and
build the building blocks of the
knowledge in your own mind over time
rather than kind of being spoonful fire
hose of information and I expected to
regurgitate it one of my favorite
courses on brilliant other than all the
stuff on computer science which is like
my especially subject outside of
medicine but they've got a really cool
course on scientific thinking and this
course explores the laws of physics and
engineering and just helps you generally
get an understanding of how the world
Works brilliant are also constantly
updating their lessons and courses so
for example they released a new course
on crypto back when that was blowing up
so people could understand that they
have a really interesting course on
neural networks and how they work which
feeds into all the artificial
intelligence stuff and it's just a
generally great way of keeping up with
all these Topics in the field of stem so
if any of that stands up your street
then do head over to brilliant.org
forward slash deep dive and if you're
one of the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also in the video
description and in the show notes then
you'll get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
and let's get right back to the podcast
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been able
paying customer of wework for the last
two years now I discovered it during you
know when the pandemic was in the on the
verge of being lifted and I spent like
the whole year just sort of sitting in
my room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member me
and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone on my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've got soundproof
booths in which to take Zoom calls and
meetings anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode what's the deal with the
ketogenic diet loads of tech browser
particularly big on that I know I wish
they would stop so the ketogenic diet
was developed for children with epilepsy
which I think is a fairly commonly known
story now the only indication for a
ketogenic diet is for children and
adults who have epilepsy because yeah
totally yeah so we use it in clinical
practice for that Soul Purpose nothing
else and there is some really
interesting data and useful data now
that suggests that lower carbohydrate
diets are helpful for weight control but
there are inevitably consequences to
that in terms of microbiome and other
things so lower carbohydrate diets
useful and generally reasonably
sustainable for people who need to lose
a lot of weight over a long period of
time but ketogenic diets where the
carbohydrate intake is so low are like
almost consistently completely
unsustainable for people meaning that
they then fail on potentially another
diet they feel like they're a failure
nothing can happen they can't do
anything their kind of self-esteem a
self-est efficacy goes right down people
give up on weight loss and everything
gets to be a disaster so it's all about
balance and managing things properly and
no qualified dietitian or other
Healthcare professional or would
recommend a ketogenic diet to anyone
because we are aware of the consequences
it's just the
I don't know shouty people that not
properly qualified in this area that are
doing it
what are your thoughts on one meal a day
I mean can you get 30 plants in one meal
a day alley probably not yeah exactly
that's my thoughts on it essentially
that's a summary of my thoughts on it
you cannot possibly get all of the
nutrients that you need for one day in
one meal because you can't physically
fit it into your body and so ultimately
you're gonna be affecting your gut
health affecting your General Health and
you know if you think about the
opportunities that you've got to have
oily fish twice a week for example
you're gonna have to think about that
over one meal rather than having more
than one opportunity to have those
really healthy things so if you think
you can fit at least five portions of
fruits and vegetables and nuts and seeds
and all the other stuff that you need to
have to be healthy into one meal a day
that's up to you but I don't think it
will fit in your body
um uh what's the deal with the carnivore
diet oh my God the carnivore diet is
just I think one of the worst things
that's happened recently isn't it it's
it's horrendous for your gut health
right horrendous you're obviously
completely starving off your microbiome
these guys are inevitably going to end
up with and it is mostly guys I'm going
to end up with heart disease with high
cholesterol with all kinds of problems
but their colons are going to be an
absolute mess because they're basically
only feeding those negative bacteria
that are having Health negative Health
consequences because the diet is just
protein so for anyone that doesn't know
and please don't Google it the carnivore
diet is where you just eat meat and
there was this guy I can't remember what
he called himself now but he was like
the king of the carnivores right the
liver King liver King oh yeah this dude
was eating like raw brain and testicles
and all kinds of stuff and saying that
you had to do this stuff to follow
proper ancestral lifestyle and then it's
recently come out that of course he was
actually just taking loads of steroids
and loads and like spending something
like 15
000 a month on his steroid regime to
look the way that he did whilst all the
time he was amassing like millions of
followers claiming that he wasn't taking
any steroids at all and just just for a
little reminder for anyone's not sure
anyone who looks like they're taking
steroids is definitely
I don't doubt it just go with your
instinct and think yeah it would be
really difficult to get like that just
from eating brains and and testicles
right it just doesn't work like that
it's not how the body works
um
what do you think so
how do dietitians feel about
the word diet
great question I think it's it's such a
difficult world that we live in and I
guess when the word dietitian came along
it wasn't associated with diet culture
and the negative sides like aspects of
that that there is now
and you know we sort of go through these
discussions as a profession about
whether dietitian is a good word for us
because it has people often still say to
me also you help people to lose weight
like I don't do that at all we're very
medical as you know and like dietitian
might be working in
in with people with kidney problems or I
worked in intensive care for a long time
we worked with cancer patients we just
do this medical stuff and none of it is
about trying to help people lose weight
some some dietitians do work in obesity
management but it's maybe you know less
than 10 of the profession
so diet and diet culture are synonymous
with bad news and this way that all
these diets that we're talking about the
keto diet carnivore diet all this kind
of stuff even fasting is all about
making generally healthy people thinner
and being fixated on thinness as part of
people feeling better about themselves
because we live in this kind of fat
phobic Society it's all very complicated
these days and I think one of the things
that's important to recognize is that
being very overweight and eating a very
poor quality diet not exercising not
looking after your body being very
stressed is really really bad for you
but actually all of our bodies are meant
to be a different shape and size and
sometimes bits of our lives are
dedicated to being as healthy as we can
be and other times in your life you
might be raising children or working two
jobs or having a side hustle as well and
if you add the pressure of being as thin
as you possibly can be or shredded as
you possibly can be into that mix you're
putting so much pressure on yourself and
it's just not healthy for you and you're
going to be full of cortisol which makes
you carry more weight anyway so we have
to have kind of a elevated view on our
body shape and size what's normal and
healthy for us might be normal not be
normal and healthy for somebody else so
diet culture and dieting is a
complicated and difficult area that is
very uh controversial these days
interestingly so it's something we I'm
constantly thinking about in terms of my
title as a dietitian because it just
feels not quite accurate as to what I do
really
how has
a diet culture
evolved over the last let's say 20 30
years it would have been the trends that
you've seen of
so if about my mom's Generation all that
they were exposed to in terms of female
bodies were very very slim women on
magazines right so in magazines in books
on the TV sometimes but it was very much
the thin ideal so the thinner the better
at all costs there's no such thing as
too thin Kate Moss generation of like
then sort of bit later Kate Moss
generation of nothing tastes as good as
skinny feels these are all the messages
funnily enough conversation my friend
this morning about the sidebar of Shame
which was basically pictures of this is
in more in the 90s of like Jennifer
Lopez with a tiny bit of cellulite on
the beach circled saying sidebar of
shame in the Daily Mail in women's
magazines it was all about the thinner
the better and anyone seen to be
carrying any additional weight was
shamed circle around the bit that they
were saying was not good all that kind
of stuff and then of course when women
did lose too much weight they were told
they were too skinny and everything was
awful and they had something wrong with
them but they've just been shamed into
it and then we had the social media and
we had Instagram so I think about
Instagram coming in something like 11
years ago now young women are exposed to
all sorts of different shapes and sizes
of bodies now but the the body shape
that we're told that we have to have now
is this kind of tiny waist massive bum
big boobs but you have to have a thigh
gap and you have to be able to fit your
fingers around hands around your waist
and and you have to do this and you have
to have visible abs and everything else
and a lot of that stuff is obviously not
necessary obviously it's physiologically
impossible unless you've had surgery
right so if you're doing loads of squats
unless you have a very specific pelvic
shape if you're doing loads and loads of
squats you're going to build up your
inner thigh muscles as well so you end
up without a thigh gap but you might
have a big bum before I've not got a
thigh gap that you want it so you keep
working you keep trying you think I'm
not losing enough weight I'm not doing
it right but actually those people that
you're looking at are either posing in a
very unnatural way or they've had
surgery or they're editing their
pictures so we're now exposed to this
kind of and you know even like the
Kardashians lead a lot of this body uh
body image
stuff in my opinion
and in everyone else's opinion now now
they're going very skinny and that's
really hard because people women have
maybe eaten a bit extra to try and bulk
up or maybe they've had this surgery to
make their bum bigger and other
Kardashians are getting really skinny
and they're like oh my God what am I
going to do my bum implants taken out
how am I supposed to manage this right
so social media has caused this absolute
chaos with body image and with dark
culture and just like
it's some interesting examples of this
like nobody in the world told like from
a nutrition professional perspective
told people to start drinking plant milk
that was almost entirely led by like a
social media campaign of people saying
shouldn't be drinking Dairy and then
plant milk has come along and taken up
that space
nobody in a nutrition professional
perspective has said that's better for
you in any capacity than drinking dairy
milk because it's not fundamentally
dairy's got loads of really important
nutrients in they're harder to find
that's where on your diet
but somebody came along and I could name
her but you might want to edit out
deliciously Ella came along and said
everyone should be plant-based and not
drink Dairy and now there's this huge
market for plant-based milks right at
that time so we're talking about this
kind of 11 year ago no nutrition
qualifications by the way 11 years ago
along comes Joe Wicks and tells everyone
to eat coconut oil coconut oil is full
of saturated fat and we worked so hard
as nutrition professionals to get people
away from saturated fat and have more
olive oil and now suddenly everyone's
eating loads of coconut oil because Joe
Wicks told them to again no nutritional
qualifications absolutely no health
benefits to eating coconut oil but these
nutrition Trends seep into society from
influences and from social media
platforms and it causes physical harm so
if we get a wave and you know lots of
people would say it's inevitable that we
have a wave of young women and men who
have osteoporosis in their 40s because
they never gain the bone density that
you get from having dairy in your diet
consistently up until the age of 30.
is delicious it's deliciously Ella or
other influences culpable for that are
they responsible
I think so but no one's gonna they're
not they've not got any governing body
that says that they should be equally if
we did
have a big spike in heart attacks from
people having loads of coconut oil is
Joe Wicks responsible maybe but he's not
culpable because he's not there's not
many credentials in the area there's no
one governing what he's saying there's
like social media has become a public
health platform
but nobody is managing it nobody's
protecting it no one's making sure it's
okay skinny teas giving people diarrhea
teaching people purging behaviors like
it's a mess and it's so hard to break
through that stuff and I think
dietitians have such an important voice
there but it's really hard to break
through and that is where now diet
culture is like on acid and it's so
dangerous for people
yeah
I did I've done two dexa scans in the
last uh sort of 12 months first I'll say
in June then was in December and the one
in June showed me that I was like 24
body fat or something which was a real
shock to my system because I just kind
of assumed I was like 17 18 or something
just based on how I think I look
um and the guy who did the scan uh was
like yeah you know in terms of in terms
of your upper body your sort of median
for people the sorts of people that have
dexa scans are generally more Health
consciously type people for your lower
body you're in the 15th percentile so do
more squats kind of thing
um but also I had tons of visceral
adipose tissue it was like 70 something
and then I had another scan six months
later uh I'd lost 3kg annoyingly like 60
of it was muscle rather than fat
um and the guy was like yes because not
enough protein and not enough actually
going to the gym which is what maintains
muscle when you when you've lost weight
the visceral adipose tissue went down to
sort of the 50s from the 70s which was
good
um body fat was still like 23 percent
um and so I was thinking
part of me was thinking I want to get
shredded
um just for the aesthetic stuff
but then another part of me well when I
when I spoke to this other health coach
he was like well it's not it's not
really about the six-pack abs but
actually we do want to get this visceral
adipose tissue down and especially with
my background South Asian basically
apparently a lot of fat congregates
around our beddies
um and visceral adipose tissue equals
bad therefore I should try and reduce my
overall body fat because that gets rid
of some of the visceral adipose tissue
to what extent is this reasonable
strategy or what have I gotten wrong in
this analysis no no I mean all of what
you've said is true so visceral fat
which is the fat that collects around
your organs is really not good for our
General Health it's very metabolically
active and interact with our body it
creates inflammation in the body which
we know to be really negative for us so
visceral fact something we need to
control how much visceral fat you have
is inevitably going to be linked to your
genetics so you will always have more
than perhaps so when we do these studies
the dexa studies to show what's average
are mainly done on white people and so
we don't necessarily have a good gauge
of what might that might look like in
South Asian people for example what
might be normal so actually if you did
compare that and BMI is the same
actually so we give a lower BMI and
waist hit ratio for South Asian people
now than we would for white people
because South Asian people carry more
weight centrally in that so you might be
lighter and that's more dangerous so
actually if we looked at studies that
include people from all different
backgrounds there might be a slightly
different ratio for you of what would be
normal right because of your background
so that's something to think about I
don't believe that data exists but I
could be wrong
um so it's something to do with thinking
practically about what's right for you
and whether you can physically do that
but focusing on something like visual
facts is a useful measure of thinking
okay how am I gonna improve and impact
my long-term Health unfortunately most
people are only interested in athletics
to the detriment of all the other things
and then that can end up with all kinds
of different problems so you could get
really really fixated on that number and
actually it's not moving as fast as you
want it to and that can be really
difficult for you because you end up in
a bit of a pit of going to the gym twice
a day and hardly eating anything or just
eating protein and go down this spiral
whereas actually just having a gauge on
it having an eye on it and making sure
it's not becoming out of control and in
a really unhealthy level is probably the
most important thing to think about
how do you feel about the visible ABS
culture I mean I think it's
unfortunately I think it's much more
dangerous for women than it is for men
so
that's not fair I think that
there's this culture now for men and I
really feel sad that women haven't
brought men with them on the positive
body positivity Journey because I think
that the
like Diet culture journey is really just
in its infancy for men really but what I
notice is if you watch Netflix for
example
you'll see men who don't apparently go
you might follow this man all through
his day and he's doing all sorts of
different things but not once has he
gone to the gym but when he takes a
shirt off in the evening he's got this
absolutely ripped six-pack so young men
are like oh he's not really going to gym
but somehow he looked like every man has
this under their even lawyers who are
clearly working like 24 hours a day
seem to have this amazing six-pack how
is that possible how do I get that I
should have that too and of course
that's not how it is right that's just
not what the average man looks like but
that's what men are now expected to kind
of try and emulate or feel that they're
expected to try and emulate and you know
the lower your body fat percentage goes
the lower your testosterone gets the
more higher risk you have injury and
generally your energy is going to be
crap if you speak to people who are men
who've been on the front covers of like
Men's Health and stuff like that and you
ask them how they were feeling at the
time that they shredded down for that
photo shoot they'll tell you that they
felt horrendous that they were depressed
if I awful that eating out in ages
haven't eaten with their wife for ages
haven't seen their kids for ages they're
just in the gym all the time you know
that and they've not drunk enough water
they've like fasted from water to try
and get really shredded but that's kind
of the you know the Panacea that's what
people are aiming for right that's what
people think they need to be looking
like so that's dangerous and toxic in
and of itself when we think of women
actually having visible abs for most
women means getting your body fat
percentage down to something that we
relatively similar to men so something
below like 19 let's say but in order for
a woman most women this is on average
looking at the data most women need a
body fat percentage of at least 22 to 25
to have a regular menstrual cycle so
women are starving themselves down to
body fat percentage of somewhere between
17 and 19 to get visible ABS meaning
that their menstrual cycle has probably
stopped on average we look at it and of
course some women carry a lot more
weight on the bottom and not so much in
the middle so they might have leaner
abdomens naturally
but on average when we look at the data
most women with a six-pack probably
won't be menstruating and of course not
having a period is associated with all
kinds of really negative Health outcomes
not least of all uh you know bone
density problems and all sorts of things
that are actually long-term health
things that can cause all kinds of harm
but one of the questions that people
love to ask I think in media type stuff
I've seen and so I'm going to ask it to
you with that caveat with with the
apology but uh is
can you be overweight and healthy yeah
for sure yeah yeah so some people just
are naturally supposed to be heavier
than what the BMI tells us to be and in
my practice I would say that those are
the people who were noticed that they
were heavier as children and maybe they
carry and weight on their lower body or
on their arms maybe they're women who've
got quite big breasts that kind of stuff
they generally just are naturally
heavier maybe their mum's also a bit
heavier and or their grandma and their
Grandma was a bit heavier that kind of
genetic predisposition to carrying a bit
more weight but what I'm talking about
is women who eat really well who look
after their bodies who exercise who love
exercise we're doing really good stuff
and who look after their mental health
and they're not eating compulsively they
don't feel out of control with their
relationship with food they're eating
really healthily but ultimately they are
still heavier than what their doctor
might like them to be right and those
are healthy people those are overweight
but healthy people and what we have is
this interesting data around people who
are thin on the inside but fat on the
outside tofi and foti people who are fat
on the outside but thin on the inside
what does that mean so then you could be
thin the outside but fat on the inside
like with this visceral fat we're
talking yeah this could be a naturally
very thin person but maybe you're
smoking maybe you're drinking too much
maybe you you know don't eat well you
don't look after that you never exercise
so you might look thin so your doctor
goes sure you can have IVF you can have
all this treatment you can do these
things
but you actually a very very unhealthy
person and just some small Lifestyle
Changes might sort everything out for
you but you could be an overweight
person overweight in inverted commas who
looks after their body everything
beautifully doesn't have hardly any
visceral fat but they are naturally a
heavier set person and they're denied
treatment for things like infertility
and that kind of stuff because their BMI
isn't what their GP wants it to be so
it's a big kettlefish and it's very
difficult but yes you can absolutely be
heavier than
though society would like you to be and
be a very healthy person
I've I've heard on a couple of
usually
um kind of men Centric podcasts
um this idea of and usually right wingy
type podcasts that oh my God Work
culture has gone mad you look at that
plus size model on that on that
Instagram page look at that plus size
model on that magazine cover yes we get
that like body shaming bad yes we get
that like super super skinny also bad
but like come on surely you're
encouraging women to become fat that's
true that kind of narrative I mean when
we think about
um my mum's generation again where they
only saw very very skinny women and
certainly to the early stages of social
media where we only saw a very
particular shape and size of women and
we still see that on TV on average and
everything else when we see that we
don't see any other body shapes and
sizes represented it means that the
women who can never be that shape and
size despite however much exercise and
healthy eating whatever else they do
they just feel completely unrepresented
and those people who you know you might
follow the latest diet Trends every new
one that comes out but it's not working
for you because you're just never
supposed to be that shape and size it's
not healthy for you it's impossible for
you to maintain get there or maintain it
so you read the development eating
disorder or you develop what we call
disordered eating where you're feeling
terrible about your body shape and size
all the time you're bouncing from you
know either completely restricting or
overeating all the time and struggling
to maintain your a healthy relationship
with food you're constantly thinking
about food it's the only thing you're
ever thinking about you're hating your
body and thinking about food all the
time occupying all of your brain space
imagine what you could do with all that
rain space but it stopped
um when we don't have any representation
that's the two camps that people fall
into so they either stay super super
skinny or they really struggle with
disordered eating relationship with food
in their body what we need is this
representation
and of course we don't need any
glorification of poor health but what I
see from these girls that are you know
these plus size models who are on the
cover of Cosmopolitan if you look on
their Instagram they're skipping they're
doing yoga they're doing amazing things
they're doing incredible stuff they're
not generally the the people who are
shown are not the people who are on
YouTube
eating excessively and everything else
right those are that's a really Niche
kind of fetishy category actually but I
think that these heavier women who are
naturally heavier on our plus size
models are being grouped in with them
and that's certainly not how it is in
reality all right so we took a little
bit of a tea break I did the thing that
you that you suggested while I well
while I was waiting for the tea to steep
or Brew or whatever the hell that's
called I pulled myself a glass of water
and I drank it perfect and that's such
an easy thing it's so nice when you can
like attach a habit to something else
definitely I think that's where
dietitians come in really handy because
we understand like
if you see a different sort of nutrition
professional sometimes you're given this
like idealized Diet of the perfect
things you're eating and drinking and
it's just completely unrealistic whereas
because we work in hospitals where
people who just don't have access to
funds and stuff like that for the
majority of our career you kind of
understand what people actually eat like
and how they really behave and you can
really help people to kind of change
those behaviors rather than just going
here's your diet plan off you go yeah
um uh on on that note are there any
other sort of quick easy tips that
someone can can take away that will just
level up their life I think like
snacking on nuts and seeds and stuff
like that is just so helpful just adding
add things in put like a jar like if
you're someone who eats in the car and
you notice it on heat unhealthy things
in the car put like a jar of Trail Mix
in the car go to a health food store or
whatever you can afford to you can go to
um poundland and get loads of different
nuts and seeds and stuff and mix them up
in a big jar and put that in your car
and it'll help you to kind of keep full
for ages and have nice things to snack
on interesting so I've always thought
like I really like nuts but then I think
all nuts high calorie bad so
interestingly there's great data to show
that the less you chew nuts the less
nutrition like the less fat you absorb
from them so don't choke but if you
follow them yeah you just can't act
they're very difficult to digest in a
really positive way so ultimately the if
you eat nuts you just don't you probably
absorb 50 of the fat from the nuts that
you actually eat because most of us
aren't chewing it down if you have
peanut butter for example then you end
up absorbing much more of the fat
because obviously it's processed and you
can eat it better yeah because like when
I'm driving especially I'll I'll stop at
a Services charge the car or whatever
and then I'll be like oh I really want
to eat something yeah and I'll sometimes
do fall to like Smarties but like I
think replacing that with like just a
nut mix option yeah perfect yeah and
even put some like put a few chocolate
raisins in there why not treat yourself
you know make it nice okay so the water
thing that
I mean not so great for your bike buying
but they're also great for keep like
General healthy fats and they're also
positive keeping you full and all that
kind of stuff so really good for satiety
I think it is a little bit about
counting your fruits and veg so just
going all right how many plants have I
got in this meal how many plants I've
got in that meal and one of the things
that I do habitually is just as I said
before just zoom out on my diet a little
bit and go okay I haven't really had any
fish this week I'm in a restaurant
trying to make a decision have I eaten
chicken this week have I eaten fish have
I eaten meat what have I had for me I'm
also thinking where am I my menstrual
cycle do I need some red meat do I need
a bit more iron that kind of stuff it's
just sort of trying to think a little
bit more strategically about your diet
without having really strict rules
because that's important and helps you
with your general mental health and
well-being nice I like that yeah I find
often when I go to a restaurant I'm
Paralyzed by choice but if I zoom out
and think huh I've only had one person
to fish this week great that makes sense
that's easy exactly fantastic
um you looked up a few studies while we
were taking taking a break let's pretend
I just knew them off the top of my head
though yeah nice I am joking
yeah so um what are some fun studies
that I I love hearing about studies yeah
so there's some great research on
probiotics and both the gut brain axis
so how when we're stressed we have these
gut symptoms and how probiotics can help
to control those gut symptoms so one in
particular so there's 55 healthy
volunteers given probiotic another group
are given a placebo so we can measure
the difference and once you have the
probiotic have a significant reduction
of psychological stress significant
reduction in cortisol so these like
chemical parameters of Stress and
Anxiety that we can measure so it's not
just how people say they're feeling it's
these objective measures so I'm talking
about cerebiome which is these two
combination of two particular probiotic
bacteria which we have in the smart
probiotic shown to significantly reduce
cortisol in people who are taking it in
comparison to Placebo magic people don't
believe this stuff until they see some
of this research right it's so important
to look at it and they also see a
decrease in depression scores so
people's perceived how they're feeling
mood scores that kind of stuff which is
pretty magic I think one of the really
important things that we often miss when
we're thinking about productivity and
focus and concentration is that anxiety
is like the anti-focus concentration
hormone right when you're anxious you
generally procrastinate you don't do
anything you get really fidgety so you
can't concentrate on anything at all so
really with a lens of thinking about why
we struggle with focus on concentration
we've got to think about anxiety so if
we can reduce anxiety and reduce
cortisol we're going to be in a much
better Flow State we're going to be able
to focus much better so if we're
focusing our our thoughts about this on
reducing of cortisol we can think that
then the counteraction of that will be
that you'll be able to concentrate and
focus much better
we've also done some great words there's
great research on depressed patients
given probiotics and seeing Improvement
in anxiety Sleep Quality stress and that
in that study in particular they were
given the probiotic for eight weeks and
those results lasted for eight weeks
longer once they stopped taking the
probiotic which is pretty magic so
you've got bacteria adapt and change
over time and then they can become a
less stressed microbiome so your
ecosystem and your colon sort of evolves
with you so it evolves depending on what
you feed it and it evolves depending on
what external facts is going on so if
there is a lot of stress you become a
more stressed ecosystem into including
your colon and that then helps to
release more cortisol makes you a more
stressed person so it's this feedback
loop between your gut and your
environment whereas if we can break that
feedback loop by introducing some
probiotic bacteria that help to control
stress it can help to have long lasting
effects in your colon which is Magic and
then we've got another great study with
75 healthy volunteers given Placebo or
probiotics and again really significant
reduction in stress-induced GI symptoms
so that diarrhea that you get when
you're feeling anxious and stressed we
can see that reduce just with taking
these two particular strains of
probiotics which is pretty magic that's
really cool
sick I'm gonna take this more more
regularly now yeah every day please cut
that out because
one thing that is common for people to
hear if they go to a doctor about
something any kind of bowel symptoms is
oh you've got a bit of IBS yeah sure
what does a bit of IBS mean nothing
really I think it's really important
that everyone knows that if a doctor is
trying to give you a diagnosis of IBS
diagnosis of IBS is a diagnosis of
elimination so your job as a doctor is
to eliminate all the other things that
it could be before you say it's IBS so
that means that at the very least
someone should be having a blood test to
rule out any sort of inflammatory
condition and they should be having a
stool test again to look at inflammation
in the stool but also to look for any
blood in the stool which is associated
with bowel Cancers and unfortunately
bowel cancer is affecting more and more
young people we also with women we would
think about things like endometriosis
and other gynecological problems that
could cause disruption to digestion but
also bloating and that kind of stuff uh
you know cervical cancers can lead to
bloating those sorts of things so it's
so so important that your doctor does
that process of elimination before they
give you that diagnosis of IBS and I
think it can be quite empowering for
people to know that actually the nice
guidelines so that the guidelines that
tell doctors what to do that is in there
they have to do this process of
elimination before they say it's just a
bit of IBS because there is a risk that
you'll miss other much more serious
things and a lot of my patients will
have seen their doctor multiple times
before they see me and then they come
and they say my doctor said I've got IBS
and then I say actually I just think we
need to do a few more tests I don't
think this has been ruled out and they
end up having something more serious and
that's you know it could have been
diagnosed years ago
hmm what can we learn about gut from poo
testing and blood testing so stool
testing at your GP so if someone comes
to see me and I think I think we need
some more stool tests the sorts of stool
tests I might ask for would be things
like
um a sort of fecal cow protectant so it
measures how much inflammation is in
your poo and that tells us if there's
actual inflammation in your bowel
someone who has IBS should never have
inflammation in their bowel it's just
not part of the IBS picture but people
have inflammatory bowel disease for
example May well have info what will
have inflammation in their bowel itself
when they're in have active disease
um we can also look for things like
parasites so sometimes people come and
they've got like IBS that developed when
they went on holiday somewhere and
actually they've got some residual
Giardia or another parasite that they
picked up that kind of thing we can also
look for things like H pylori which is a
particular type of bug that lives in
your stomach or lining and that can
cause reflux and those kinds of things
and it's again a simple stool test that
can be done for that so there are lots
of medical level store tests we can do
we can check your pancreatic function
with your stool test that kind of thing
but the sort of stool tests that people
are really interested in now are these
microbiome tests that you can have done
so these are available commercially and
they are interesting so in the last week
I've been analyzing a load of stool
tests as part of the heights probiotic
trial and we're looking at people's
stall tests but there's real limitations
to them so we've got really interesting
raw data and what we need to do with
that data is pair up with what people
are eating what their lifestyle is like
try to use the clues from their clinical
conversation with them to then look at
their stool tests and try and match up
why this particular thing is different
for them so for example you could look
and you could say this person's got more
higher levels of some pathogenic
bacteria and you need to say did you
have food poisoning anytime in the last
kind of few years or so and then we can
go okay that's probably why but it might
also just be a bit High because their
levels of good bacteria are a bit too
low and we need to balance it all out
it's all about ratios and I guess the
main thing to take from this is that if
you're going to do it on your own the
chances are you're going to end up with
a load of information that you don't
know what to do with and it can be
potentially really frightening and if
you have existing gastrointestinal
problems they're more anxious and
worried you are the worse your problems
are going to be right so it's not
necessarily helpful to do it if you are
someone who is feeling anxious and you
think that might be contributing to your
gut symptoms ultimately there's really
no point in doing it if you're someone
who lives with any kind of gut condition
because we just don't have data for what
is normal for someone who has IBS for
example so we've got loads of data for
what's normal in healthy people or
what's average and healthy people but we
don't have data on people who've got IBS
IBD that kind of stuff so it's just not
a good idea to do if you've got any kind
of gut symptoms and actually if you come
and see someone like myself or someone
from my team we can based on your
symptoms and what's going on for you
have a really good guess at what's going
on in bacteria wise right so if you say
to me I passing really fast man and gas
I'll say what does it smell like and
they might say it smells very eggy and I
think they've got too many of the ones
that produce too much sulfur let's work
on managing those and if you say I've
got really bad bloating I'll say oh
you've probably just got really loads of
Rapid fermenting bacteria in there and
we can try and modulate the proportions
of those so that things get a bit more
comfortable so it's you really don't
need to have one ever but sort of
academically speaking they're always
quite fascinating
so I was in Miami a couple days ago and
everyone there seemed to have some kind
of longevity regimen with their nads and
nmns and all their stacks and all this
kind of stuff and one thing that they'll
sort of use cold showers ice plungers
hyperbaric chambers even some of them
one thing that they all seem to have
done was some kind I think this sort of
microbiome stool testing because they
were like oh I did my stool test and it
told me that actually for me avocados
are really bad and for my May avocados
are good like what I and I was a bit
like what how does that work what's
going on there I think that what they
are referring to is
um some personalized nutrition program
that does stall testing but also does
blood testing and genetic testing yeah
yeah so they're looking at that full
parameters of things and whilst that's
interesting ultimately the the vast
majority of the advice both on
microbiome testing but also on genetic
testing everything else it's going to be
roughly the same right roughly the same
which means that you you've got a
slightly higher propensity to me for
cardiovascular disease for example and I
have a slightly higher propensity for
diabetes but the doctor advice for those
two things is going to be the same eat
loads of plants have some oily fish be
careful with high fat foods that kind of
stuff yeah so the dietary advice is
going to be roughly the same regardless
of what's going on and some people might
find out from that kind of stuff that
they don't handle fats very well so they
might find out that actually for their
mother card too much avocado isn't a
good thing but most people aren't out
there smashing so much avocado that's
going to have a negative impact on their
health right so ultimately those tests
are interesting and some people find
them useful but in in practice for most
people it creates this kind of real
anxiety and that's where people can end
up booing bananas in a lecture theater
right that's where people get too
fixated on it and worried about things
that actually in the grand scheme of
things are not something you need to be
worrying about
these are generally just sorry to
interpret you these are generally people
with far too much time on their hands to
think about their longevity and they're
not people who are living in the real
world but their influence is huge on all
of us right because they are the sort of
top tier in terms of financials and so
we kind of emulate them and we think
that that's part of what got them to
where they are but actually it's the
years of them grafting and eating
deliveroo every night that got them to
where they are it's not them focusing on
hyperbaric chambers and all that kind of
stuff yeah these guys all have way too
much money way too much money on way too
much time in the house
um I was like having a chat with my
girlfriend last night and we were we
were talking about sauna use because
there's all this stuff around like oh
heat shock proteins and heat shock
therapy and all that all that kind of
stuff and I was thinking yeah you know
you know they say like on on Hebrew and
lab he says four times a day and we
couldn't quite remember like whether it
was 13 minutes or 14 minutes and 15
minutes and she made a very good point
she was like well if you don't go to the
sauna at all it does not matter at all
like whether whether you're whether
you're 55 minutes 58 minutes just trying
to like get to the store at least once a
week first and then once you're at the
point where you're going four times a
week then worry about the optimization
yeah sure I mean also just remember that
like 99 of the population don't have
access to a sauna so and they're kind of
okay yeah
um but I think it illustrates that thing
which like I I definitely have a
propensity for this where
if I don't have 100 of the information
I'm gonna go zero percent of the way
sure sure and actually I should just go
80 of the way and then worry about
optimizing and I think that's just
generally really good advice isn't it
it's like those small steps that you
take and the things that last and that
are easy and if you try and sort of have
it stack that makes a massive difference
rather than trying to overhaul
everything and get to details oriented
nice
um okay loads of somewhat unrelated
things which are all I mean obviously
related to the gut that I want to ask
you about so I'm just going to shoot 100
questions your way uh what's the deal
with protein shakes uh depends on how
you're taking them or using them for but
most people don't need them so most
people get plenty of protein in their
diet if you're someone who is trying to
build muscle rapidly and you're busy and
it's difficult to get enough kind of
meals in the day then fair enough you
could use a protein shake but it's
really important to look for one that
doesn't have emulsifiers and colorings
and all this stuff in it preservatives
because you're just causing yourself
more problems for later they've got
these Health Halo that we talked about
that people think it's really healthy
because it's protein shaped when
actually it's probably like birthday
cake flavored and it's got loads of
different things in it that you don't
want in your body so I generally
recommend to people to either use a whey
protein isolate or a pea protein isolate
if they're vegan and then you can blend
that up with like some berries and maybe
some kefir or some berries and some like
oats for example and you can make
yourself like a really healthy really
good tasting protein shake that's still
got the same protein structures in it
the thing that you really need for
muscle building but it's not going to
have any lactose in it it's not going to
have any other additives in it and the
things you're trying to avoid nice any
particular brands that you recommend
depends on how bougie people are so
um the organic protein company have a
really great whey protein isolate with
literally nothing else in it and so no
emulsifies or anything else so that's a
really good choice nice
but it's expensive
okay here's another thing I've heard uh
blending veg is bad because you lose a
lot of the benefits of veg once it's in
a blender sure so when we uh blend
anything it's kind of a step towards
processing it right but so is cooking
and so is other things that we do that
are fine for us and we do lose some of
the fiber structure but we maintain all
the nutrients so if you're talking about
kind of uh putting it in a blender and
you have all of it it's slightly
different so if you're juicing something
you lose all the fiber if you're juicing
something but if you're just blending it
you maintain a lot of the the foods that
your gut bacteria want so you're still
getting loads of good stuff from that
and there's no harm in doing it the harm
will not harm but the problem that
people run into is a bit like when we're
talking about oranges and juicing you
can end up having way more fruit than
you would normally have or be able to
physically eat in a sitting but blend it
up you can just drink it super easily so
I usually recommend people do is add
some like spinach in there add some kale
in there bulk it out with some veggies
and balance that out with some fruit so
that it's kind of a bit more of a
balance between fruits and vegetables
all right I'm gonna try and find a
decent recipe for this stuff so like I
can put some oats put some organic
whatever protein powder some frozen
berries some frozen veg yeah stick some
seeds in some peanut likes Mixed Nut
Butter would be great in there yes
um on the note of juices and blending
and stuff what's the deal with juice
cleanses and like celery juice and like
this kind of stuff that people do I mean
it's an absolutely terrible idea all of
it so I've got a very good friend Dr
Rachel Kent who is um she's an amazing
researcher at King's College and she her
sort of Journey she she researches the
impact of Health Tech on our general
well-being and and lives and she started
that journey into doing that because she
did a juice cleanse she was just doing
it for General Health she didn't lose
weight but she just read that juicing
was a really good idea she cut
everything out she's doing like a bit of
a detox type thing in inverted commas
and end up in hospital with terrible
kidney stones it was an intensive care
with sepsis and everything because she'd
followed this guy's juicing advice that
she's seen online and realized that this
was a disaster and now she does amazing
Research into the impact of like calorie
tracking and that kind of stuff on your
General Life uh so juice cleansers are
dangerous and worrying and something
that we definitely shouldn't be doing
anything that kind of uh involves
let's say the word detoxing it's just
nonsense so if you do something like a
juice cleanse you're actually depriving
your body of loads of really really
important nutrients meaning it's got to
work much much harder and in that
process of your body working much harder
it's releasing more things that we might
consider to be toxic like oxidative
stress and that kind of stuff because
you're just not allowing your body to
work in its normal way you're making
your liver work really hard to make your
kidneys work really hard and that means
that you're producing more stress in
your body which is actually physically
harmful to you so I don't have a problem
with people having a juice as part of
their you know adding a few more
vitamins into their diet and stuff like
that fine but if you're doing like a
juice cleanse or detox really bad news
terrible Health consequences for lots of
people and absolutely no health benefits
nice um there seems to be a lot of
advice on a tick tock these days about
the gut gut talk what's your what's your
view on gustock I mean I've not seen any
good advice on gut talk apart from what
me and the girls from the TV show have
been trying to produce there's some
really terrible stuff on there including
you know I think they call it like a
cheer shower internal shower that kind
of stuff where people are trying to
flush themselves out of things and it's
a terrible breeding ground for you know
a bit like Instagram is a terrible
breeding ground for terrible advice that
can cause all kinds of trouble
what's the what's going on with colonic
cleanses and colonic irrigation as like
a health fat yeah like a really bad idea
so if we take colonic irrigation as an
example most people are going for
colonic irrigation will be going because
they have some kind of digestive problem
that they're worried about so it might
be that they're just feeling a bit
bloated or it might be that they've got
a bit of diarrhea or constipation so
they're going to a beauty salon
effectively to have colonic irrigation
and what happens in that is they pass a
tube up your bottom and then introduce a
lot of water into the bowel and that
essentially kind of flushes out all of
the whatever's in your colon your
Colon's a meter and a half long right
it's a big organ and so actually it's
got a lot of stuff in there that's
supposed to be in there stuff that's
feeding your microbiome bits of it that
actually oh your microbiome that you
want to keep in there they're really
important
um but also if you've got any gut
symptoms and then you fill your colon
with loads of water and put it under
pressure you're at risk of perforation
right because the person who's a beauty
person who does your colonic irrigation
doesn't know doesn't have these skills
to find out whether actually you've got
a bowel cancer or you've got something
structurally wrong with your bowel that
is causing those symptoms maybe your GP
doesn't even have the skills to do that
you might have diverticular disease
where the structure is affected and
there's narrowings and there's like bits
of the bowel wall that are really
vulnerable introduce a load of water
into that environment put it under
pressure perforations can happen really
easily there's absolutely no health
benefits to colonic irrigation but loads
of reasons that everybody should
absolutely avoid it fantastic
um a lot of people seem to be going on
gluten-free diets these days what's the
deal with collision-free diets yeah
super trendy right so about one percent
of the UK population has celiac disease
so that's where gluten is physically
toxic to your bowels it causes physical
damage to the lining of the ball and a
bowel wall and that's a an autoimmune
condition so it generally inherited
autoimmune condition so in their case
gluten should absolutely be avoided at
all costs including like a tiny crumb of
gluten that could be on a chopping board
or in the same fryer so you know frying
chips and they've got had batter in
there then they can't have chips that
are fried in the same thing so those
people have to be super super careful
with gluten the rate of celiac disease
hasn't increased over the last few years
at all but the number of people on a
gluten-free diet has increased
exponentially thanks to people like
Gwyneth Paltrow and other people who are
promoting gluten-free diets as some sort
of Health elixir of course in reality
that's just a low carb diet through the
back wall back door right so we're like
I've lost loads of weight and a
gluten-free nuts just because you're not
eating carbs anymore that's the reason
you've lost weight it's not good for you
it's not helping you gluten is this tiny
little protein molecule that never did
anyone any harm apart from this one
percent of the population but it's been
completely demonized by the kind of
Wellness Community
and this sort of has pros and cons for
the Celiac Community because now
everywhere you go you can get really
good Celiac products and gluten-free
products right which is great when I
first started working as a dietitian
gluten-free bread was horrendous and you
couldn't buy a gluten-free cake anywhere
and now everywhere you go has
gluten-free options but it's also made
shop owners so restaurants that kind of
thing less worried about it so people
think you're just on a gluten-free diet
because you're being fussy as opposed to
having a true allergy so they're not
necessarily handling things carefully or
doing it because it's someone who's got
sealer disease they're doing it because
it's someone that they think is just on
a fad diet which causes all kinds of
trouble for people who do live for see
Lexy so they're pros and cons to that we
see that in other allergies as well so
like there's a couple of incidents of
like vegan food trucks giving people
Dairy with dairy allergies anaphylaxis
because they're just not being that
careful because they're just being
they're trying to be vegan but they're
not careful with contamination so people
have anaphylactic dairy allergy think
it's fighting but actually
it's not so there's all kinds of trouble
with that but ultimately again no
benefits to cutting out gluten loads of
downsides including things like effect
and quality of life so cutting out
gluten is not a good idea for anyone and
not necessary unless you have celiac
disease or some people with IBS do
struggle with tolerating gluten but it's
usually not just gluten so what I find
is people have cut out gluten they're
like I felt a bit better but it wasn't
all together better and that's because
there's lots of other things that impact
symptoms and IBS that we can do as a
clinical treatment diet so would you
suggest like would it be worth
random person just cutting out gluten
for a week and seeing seeing what
happens or is that like too much of a n
equals one bro signs yeah I mean not
unless they have any symptoms not unless
they like put massively suspect that
gluten is causing the problems and again
you know if you have some gut symptoms
and you cut out gluten you might feel a
bit better and then you might start to
feel worse again but the chances are
it's not because it was the gluten in
the first place it's because you change
your diet completely so people might cut
out gluten and then they don't eat the
burger and they don't eat the pizza and
they're getting the other things so they
feel better but actually it's not
because they cut out gluten it's because
they're not eating processed food in the
same way
we talked to live we we touched a little
bit earlier on Dairy and kind of dairy
is bad and replacing milk with oat milk
almond milk soy milk All That Jazz
um
what I guess what's the health side of
things and I guess some people having a
sort of an aversion to Dairy for the
kind of animal cruelty side of things so
how do you balance kind of these things
yeah I think it's really important to
recognize there are lots of different
reasons for coming off Dairy for being a
vegan whatever it might be and if those
are ethical or they are environmental or
they are for uh reasons of religion for
example then obviously that's absolutely
the right thing for you to do and I
would never want anyone to listen to
this and think that I'm saying that you
have to drink milk if it's really in
like in congress with your ethical
beliefs or your religious beliefs for
that matter because obviously that would
make you feel really unhappy and
uncomfortable and that's not the right
thing for anyone to do but if you're
doing it for health reasons there's
absolutely no data to show that plant
milks are better for you as a human than
dairy milk and in fact all the data that
we have today shows that people who
don't consume Dairy have much poorer
bone health so people who are vegans
have a much higher instance of bone
fracture than people who are not vegans
we have this really really interesting
period in our life so up until the age
of 30 we can continue to mineralize our
bones so all the minerals we take in in
our diet can be soaked into our bones up
until the age of 30 we call that our
Peak bone density after the age of 30
it's basically downhill from there and
your bones then acts as like a mineral
store for your body for the rest of your
life so within our bodies we always have
to maintain a really careful band of how
much calcium and how much magnesium and
how much other minerals we have in our
body because they're essential for the
contraction of our heart and the
movement of our lungs and everything
else so blood minerals will always be
the same and our body will either take
those minerals from the foods that we're
eating or it'll Leach them from our
bones in order to make sure we maintain
that really tight level of mineral
control in our bloodstream right so you
could spend all of your early 20s teens
not having enough dairy in your diet
because someone on the internet told you
to not to have it because it's not good
for you or because of something you've
seen and that makes you feel
uncomfortable but you never reach your
Peak bone mass and then every day after
that you're just depleting your stores
and so by the time you're 40 your bones
could be really brittle and we see this
in children so even if children who have
have to have even children have to have
a dairy-free diet because of dairy
allergy they'll never have as strong
bones or be as tall as children who
consume Dairy as they're growing up so
it has a direct impact on our bone
health and people say to me well people
in China don't eat dairy and they're
fine but they eat like broth with bones
in it so they're constantly having
different things in their diet that
contain loads of calcium we're talking
about a western diet type population
where we just don't have other good
sources of Bones of calcium in our diet
and the Matrix of minerals in Dairy is
really really important for our bone
health but it's also one of our main
dairies has been historically and still
continues to be one of our main sources
of iodine and iodine has an impact on
your thyroid function and we're seeing
loads and loads of young people coming
through with iodine deficiency and
thyroid problems because they've cut out
Dairy and again I'm going to say again
the influencers who told you to don't
have any like there's no consequences
for them on that it can low ironing can
cause infertility no one's got any like
no one can come back on people that told
them to do that so
Dairy is a very useful food to consume
in your diet and if you have cut it out
because you think it's healthier for you
you've been misled if you've cut it out
because you've watched documentaries
about hormones and cow's milk as well
you've been misled in the UK because
they're very different and very careful
farming practices in the UK and compared
in comparison to America where those
documentaries are made
um so let's say someone is vegan for
ethical reasons what can they do to
minimize the negative impact of not
having Dairy great question so what
they're willing to be focusing on is
making sure that all of their
plant-based products are well things are
fortified with calcium essentially
you'll also need to be taking
supplements so you need to be thinking
about iodine supplements you need to
think about B vitamin supplements
there's lots of things that you need to
be adding in but Dairy taking out Dairy
dairy's got these nine really important
nutrients that just are harder to find
elsewhere so if you are someone who has
like a family history of osteoporosis
for example you might want to think
about taking some extra supplements
getting a bone scan regularly just to
make sure you're not doing yourself any
harm there but fortified foods are
important and supplements are important
and making sure you're eating lots of
plants that do contain calcium is really
important
uh changing gears a little bit uh why
are some people saying seed oils are
evil
um I don't know I think they've just
made up
so there's uh some interesting rhetoric
I've not done any reading about this so
this is my intake this is my take on it
um there's some interesting rhetoric
around How seed oils can have an impact
like a pro-inflammatory impact on our
body and as far as I know there's no
convincing data and my my amazing
friends who are incredible researchers
in lipids and stuff like that they say
it's all nonsense so whatever they say I
go okay they know they know way more
about this than I do and they're right
so there's no data to suggest that seed
oils are having this kind of impact that
people are worried about
um as far as we know to date and none of
it's very convincing what we do know is
if we heat certain oils they can have a
more pro-inflammatory effect in the body
and that's why we think about things
like
um being careful with fried food for
example because we know that can be less
positive for us we also think about
like manufactured oils is just not being
so good for us so things like a trans
fats they're called so when fats are
changed in structure from their natural
form which might be liquid at room
temperature to being solid at room
temperature they can make like a
margarine that kind of stuff isn't very
good for us our body can't recognize it
as being a natural thing so it becomes
less positive for us so there are
certainly things in that world that are
true but I think that the seed oils hype
is is not accurate to date nice I'm just
going back to the milk thing uh
full fat semi-skim skim milk
from a obesity perspective there isn't
what we see from the data is that people
who consume whole milk generally have a
lower body weight than people who
consume skimmed milk which is really
interesting there's lots of reasons that
could be including the people who drink
skimmed milk are the people who drink it
because they struggle with their body
weight right in the first place so we
don't know for sure but actually it
seems to be that the minerals in Dairy
bind some of the fat and stop it from
being absorbed as effectively so we
maybe don't access all of the fat from
dairy which may also account for like
the French paradox stuff where they eat
a lot of cheese but actually they don't
necessarily have highlight a lot more
they have better cholesterol levels than
we do as a population so there's some
interesting stuff in there but in
general we do recommend that people
think about having lower fat dairy
products but I don't mean by that to
have like fat free yogurt that's got
loads of sweeteners and other things and
flavorings and stuff like that and I
mean to try and keep things as natural
as possible
um
we've touched on the topic over calories
quite a lot but we haven't really you
know what's your what's your own
calories very broad question I mean I
think they've become this really like
hyper fixated thing and actually it's
just a unit of measure right it's just a
unit of energy it's just a physics thing
so calories in calories out we talk
about a bit it's just a unit of energy
how much energy you're burning how much
energy you're taking in I think they've
become this like thing that we hyper
fixate on and it's worth people
remembering that labels for food are
allowed to be up to 20 incorrect so when
you're using any kind of tracking app
actually it's going to be at least 20
either side so where people are going
I've got 10 calories left I'm gonna have
one more peanut actually that's
completely nonsense right yeah well yeah
but some people our numbers people write
and that's where they can get fixated on
things and it makes things worse for
them ultimately mental health-wise and
everything else we know like the Almond
story you just cut all the nut story
just can't absorb all of the fat from
nuts so what it says on the label is not
going to be what you absorb from it when
we cook celery it's got more calories
and we don't cook it all these things
like have an impact on stuff because of
how we can access the calories and like
ultimately if we could all go away from
the calories and start thinking about
are we physically hungry degree that
would be the best way to think about
things so if you're physically hungry
you should eat to your satiety and then
you should stop eating until you feel
physically hungry again right but most
of us are making food decisions based on
the fact that we're bored or we're
lonely or we're tired or we're having
like an emotional reaction to something
so we want to eat or in a restaurant and
it's delicious so we eat way beyond our
fullness all that kind of stuff so the
way that we work in clinic with these
kinds of things is teaching people to
listen to their hunger cues listen to
their body trust their hunger hormones a
little bit more which is difficult work
and it takes a long time but counting
calories is counter-intuitive to you
learning to trust your body and having a
healthy relationship with food for the
rest of your life so we never recommend
calorie counting to anybody because it
can have this really undermining impact
on your ability to listen to your hunger
hormones and listen to your fullness
hormones and all that kind of stuff
so let's say someone does want to lose
weight
my
and this is this could be totally wrong
but I was under the impression that oh
if I'm feeling hungry it means it's
working
sure yeah yeah yeah but I mean feeling
hungry is not a good thing is it because
when you're hungry you're also really
stressed and anxious it's like courses I
find myself watching a lot of food
videos yeah when I'm feeling hungry at
night time thinking it's got to be done
to get that visceral out of birth tissue
down yeah no you don't have to do that
you have to live like that you don't
have to live that way
um you know when you're hungry you're
potentially tapping into your body's fat
stores but also when you're managing
your diet properly and your appetites
regulated properly you'll also be
tapping into your body's fat stores and
you can do that in many different ways
there's no need for you to be physically
hungry you're going to sleep hungry
means you sleep much less well you feel
hungry all night your body's keeping you
awake because it's saying we need to eat
something so actually it's about trying
to manage your appetite better through
the day so that you're not feeling
hungry at any point because when we're
hungry and when we're tired when we're
stressed we're much more likely to eat
things that we don't necessarily feel
that are in line with our health goals
at that time so for example when you're
stressed or when you're tired your brain
releases much more dopamine in response
to eating certain foods than it would if
you're not stressed and you're not tired
and there's great studies from Kings
that show that people who are tired so
sleep deprived so we sleep deprive them
in the lab and then we offer them food
freely when you're sleep deprived you
eat on average 400 to 500 calories a day
more than when you're not sleep deprived
tiredness lights when you eat something
particularly something's high in fat and
carbohydrates when you're tired the
dopamine receptors in your brain are lit
up so much more because your body's
saying yes more energy we need more
energy to stay awake same with when
you're stressed because it's fight or
flight your body's saying yes more
energy you need to run or fight
so managing stress managing tiredness
all these kinds of things those are the
things to get out the way and if your
diet regime is making you hungry so
you're really tired hunger it also goes
through all the anger and cortisol
Pathways in my brain so you're more
stressed you're more tired you're more
likely to want to overeat and not
regulate your appetite at all and that's
got loads of detrimental impacts on you
to what extent is mindful eating helpful
yes yes helpful super helpful so if you
think about
um sitting down with a small amount of
food and consuming it mindfully
listening to your body checking in so
the way that I might work this in
practice would be I would say you can
have as much of this you're going to
make yourself a meal you can have as
much of it as you want to have but first
of all I'd like you to take away kind of
a you know a smallish portion of it take
it to sofa eat it properly engage with
it try not to have lots of distractions
around you chew it properly take the
time over it and once you've finished it
have a little check-in am I feeling full
do I want more what what do I feel like
right now if you still feel hungry great
have some more but if you don't let's
just pause there go and do something
else distract yourself from the food you
don't need any more food so it's about
kind of tuning in listening chewing
properly all those things are really
important as part of that sweet bit
random but I find that I want to eat
certain things my belly bloats a little
bit it's not to the point of
uncomfortableness everybody just
sometimes I wake up in the morning and I
I look down I'm like oh you know
being a fairly flat belly and other
times I wake up in the morning like this
morning and I'm like damn how do I get
so fat overnight yeah what's going on
there so different foods for men at
different rates and produce different
type amounts of gas in our colon and
when you're colon because it is a meter
and a half long it's big organ when it's
full of gas you look bigger then you
might go for a poo and pass some gas and
you're kind of back to normal right one
of the things that we see from this kind
of Instagram culture stuff is that
people think that these people are
maintaining this very flat first thing
in the morning belly all day long when
actually everything that you eat
especially if you're a very slim person
everything you eat is almost visible in
your tummy so you'll be aware of it and
you can see it if you carry a very low
body fat percentage so all of the models
that are doing the posing are doing it
first thing in the morning and they're
probably dehydrated and starved because
that's when they look most ripped as it
were
um and actually everything you eat has
an impact and you can see it so yeah
it's normal normal to have a bit of
bloating and you know if you have a bit
of bloating after eating beans and
lentils and pulses and like garlic and
onion and that kind of stuff that's
completely normal because you've got
bacteria love it and they're fermenting
it there's nothing I can be I can be
like oh I look more bloated today and I
had avocado yesterday therefore avocados
bad for me is is there any kind of Bro
Science there that works you can think
about that so things that are most
likely to
um to ferment in your gut are these what
we call fermentable carbohydrates and
the biggest culprits that we see in
clinical practice are onion and garlic
pulses apples and pears and somebody's
kind of quite commonly consumed Foods so
if it's something that bothers you or if
it's certainly Cooks causing you any
pain if it's something that's bothering
you mentally or physically it's worth
going to see a dietitian because we can
tell you exactly what it is it's causing
it and you can choose to avoid it on the
days that you don't want to feel bloated
but then you can go after don't eat
whatever you like and be okay nice
um to what extent is glucose monitoring
for glucose spikes useful great question
I mean this is kind of outside of my
area of expertise if I'm honest my
experience of people monitoring their
blood glucose is that they get very
worried about things that are completely
physiologically normal because actually
our blood sugars are supposed to
fluctuate during the day they're
supposed to go up and down your body has
very good mechanisms of controlling your
blood glucose and if you're worried
about an increase in your blood glucose
that maintains it within the normal
range you're worrying about something
that you should just be really happy
that your body's doing that you don't
need to worry about the fact that that's
happening so I think it can it attracts
people who are hyper fixating on their
health anyway and it creates additional
anxiety about everything they put in
their mouth so ultimately I think it's
really unhelpful particularly in the
long term might be interesting as a
snapshot for a very short term under
supervision with support but I just
don't think it's something we need to be
encouraging people to do at all so if
for example I eat an avocado and it
causes a me more of a glucose Spike than
it does my mate does that tell me
anything about like I'm my the the way
my body is absorbing avocado is
different and therefore I should avoid
them or anything doesn't mean you should
avoid them no it just means that you
might want to think about combining them
with other things that has less of an
impact I mean avocado just so you know
isn't going to spike anyone's blood
sugar but yeah it's just something
banana is a better example right so if
you you and your friend both eat banana
and it's like yours more yeah are we
talking about spiking you outside the
normal range in which case is it worth
having a chat with somebody about that
or are we just talking about increasing
it slightly in which case it's fine also
really worth remembering that a banana
is not a standard food same as an
avocado like they all are a different
size and shape if you eat a banana when
it's more ripe it's got more available
sugar than when it's less ripe and as
long as your blood sugars are staying
rising and falling within the normal
range of what we know to be healthy
you've literally got nothing to worry
about
do you uh do any research or stuff
around things like the longevity side
like you know take people taking
metformin or statins and stuff even
though they are like in their 20s yeah I
mean there is some stuff around that so
when we develop the smart supplement
which is the multivitamin product for
Heights we had to unfortunately get a
bit involved in that world it is like an
interesting world I think you know I
know from my medical colleagues that
some cardiologists just start taking
statins to protect themselves from a
very young age even though they haven't
got high cholesterol but there's also
real Statin deniers in the low-carb
Community who are absolute charlatans
and are causing all kinds of harm as
well
um so it's a real mixed picture but I
think
metformin is slightly you can have an
impact on your liver and have some more
complicated side effects for some people
some of the time so yeah I just don't
think people need to be taking any
prescription medications unless they're
clinically indicated obviously but there
is interesting discussions around that
world and protecting yourself from high
blood like insulin resistance
essentially is what metformin is
protecting you from may have some
benefits but the side effects probably
outweigh it we don't have data on
healthy people taking it and the
potential side effects on that and
what's better and what's worse so I
would avoid it cool
um
I have a friend who wanted to lose a
load of weight before his wedding day
and so he took injections of
semi-glutide or liver gluten or
something like that yeah and he said it
was magical because it made a suppressed
his appetite massively made him feel
nauseous every time he ate so he stopped
eating basically yeah and he lost a lot
of weight before his wedding day yeah
um what what's going on there is it is
this some magical weight loss drug that
is not particularly I mean you described
it beautifully it makes you feel
terrible the whole time you're taking it
and really nauseous and so you don't eat
which then means you can't concentrate
anything you have headaches you feel
awful people passing out all kinds of
stuff uh so like if you want that fine
but you don't have to go down that route
right there's so many better healthier
ways of doing it and it's what you'll
probably notice is that your friend puts
on all that weight again because as soon
as you stop feeling nauseous you're like
oh my God food's my friend again and you
haven't learned anything about actually
looking after your body which is what
you know Behavior change is all about
love it
um just a couple more questions and then
I'd love to talk about the probiotic and
like the ways you guys made it and all
that kind of stuff
um we kind of touched a little bit on
kind of brain function and mood and
concentration and things I wonder if you
could just sort of you know if someone
was was being like okay Sophie how do I
how do I change my diet such that it
improves my brain function or makes me
have improves my mood what are like the
top recommendations here yeah great
question so
um Omega-3s are super super important
for our brain structure as we've talked
about and they can also help to protect
us from excess inflammation in the brain
which is linked to anxiety and
depression and stuff like that so either
make sure you're having at least two
portions of oily fish a week or take
care Omega-3 supplements B vitamins are
incredibly important for our brain
health they they produce they make
things like serotonin melatonin all of
our they make dopamine Gaba all of these
really important brain chemicals that we
really need all the time so B vitamins
are really essential for brain function
and we've got some really interesting
work showing that you can use B vitamins
in controlled circumstances in
replacement of ssris so anxiety and
depression treatments and they work in a
very similar way in the right doses at
the right moment for the right people so
B vitamin is super super important for
General brain function and brain health
and then we also think about things like
antioxidants and particularly the
anthocyanins from blueberries are
amazing for our brain health so not just
blueberries but anthocyanins come in
like red cabbage other dark purple
vegetables and there's some amazing data
showing that if children are given a
blueberry smoothie before an exam they
perform better in that exam than the
children who haven't had a blueberry
smoothie and then when we swap them over
and the level of the exam stays the same
and the first children are given the
blueberry smoothie not going to be with
me second to an R the children who had
the blueberry smoothie always perform
better than the children who didn't have
the Booboo smoothie so what we think is
happening there is it's getting better
blood to your brain and that is meaning
that you can have a better mental
performance in a very like short like
period of time so it's having that
direct impact on your brain health in
that moment and so with the smart
probiotic smart supplement we've got B
vitamins we've got other things like
iodine that are missing from people's
diets have a big impact but we've also
got vitamin D which you really need for
your brain health as well I should have
mentioned that but we've got Amigas B
vitamins and anthocyanins as kind of the
core components with the other essential
things around it and I mean I designed
this right and then you you do all the
research and you put something together
and you think you know I think that's
going to work really well given the
research that we've got but you always
always have this kind of slight
skepticism and then when the reviews
started coming in for it I was like oh
my God it's really working for people
and it really works for me as well I
think with my ADHD and stuff those
nutrients are so important to me and it
really helps in terms of brain function
for lots of people and
the reviews really kind of speak for
themselves on that
can we zoom into Vitamin D what's going
on with it sure everyone just so
everyone knows everyone should be taking
vitamin D in the winter months in the
Western Hemisphere Northern Hemisphere
sorry because we just don't get enough
sunlight so the darker your skin the
less able you are to synthesize enough
vitamin D from the sunlight so the way
that those studies are conducted are
that people of all different skin colors
are put in the Spanish sunshine in the
summer for an hour lunchtime and they
see who how much vitamin D is increased
and they can see that the darker your
skin the longer needs to be in the sun
to synthesize the same amount of vitamin
D and the light of your skin the less
amount of time you need to be in the sun
to synthesize vitamin D I'm a ginger I
synthesize more vitamin D than anyone
else in the world uh superpowers so
vitamin D is really really important for
loads of different things we think of it
more as being like a hormone now rather
than a vitamin so we see it within that
capacity and it helps to protect us from
cancer it helps protect us from it you
know it's really important for our
immune function it's really important
for our brain health vitamin D is a
really really essential nutrient for all
of us and it speaks to how our society
has changed now that we work indoors and
we stay indoors all day that you know
such a huge percentage of the population
are vitamin D deficient especially at
this time of year so Vitamin D
supplements are super super important I
take them all year round I think
everyone else should too but it's the
government recommendations are that
everyone takes them between October and
April what other supplements do you take
I take Heights basically that's all
ticks the Box
um okay let's talk about how you develop
these but before we go there uh why do
why is the word supplement often
associated with the word scam yeah I
mean because so much of it is the
industry is honestly the wild west and
so I started working with guys from
Heights I think probably about five
years ago when I was still working at
Kings and
I hadn't really realized what a mess the
industry was as a whole so it's a really
complicated thing and a difficult thing
to make a really good quality supplement
product so most people just don't bother
and worryingly anyone could go to a
supplement manufacturer anyone with no
qualifications at all and say I want to
put this much of this thing in a capsule
and they can make that and sell it and
no one's necessarily checking that and
making sure that it's safe it's the
right quantities it's suitable for
everybody it's like anyone can do it and
that's why we see all these influences
and stuff like that flogging supplements
and all this sort of stuff because they
can just make their own any day that
they want to it's a really it's a real
minefield
all of the ones that are on the shelves
in shops and stuff like that the quality
of them is incredibly variable even the
more expensive ones there's some really
like really eye-wateringly expensive
supplements now that I look at the
formulation I think
why have you put those things together
they don't work together they're
counteracting each other they're all
trying to do different things and
fighting against each other and that's
because they've not had a dietitian or a
nutritionist their qualified
nutritionist they're formulating for
them and trying to help them to make the
right decisions about what's going to
work and what's not going to work
always have a problem with the
supplement industry where something is
trying to be right for everybody so it's
like this is like a supplement for men
and I'm like well what about is it for a
man who does a lot of exercise or
doesn't do any exercise for a man who
has a sedentary job or an active job is
it for a man who is it in his 70s or in
his 30s or all different people write me
different things so it's kind of about
tailoring these sorts of things to
specifically what you're looking for
but it is a Minefield and there's also
a big population level data to suggest
that people who take supplements don't
necessarily have better longevity or
live longer or anything like that than
people who don't like it we're talking
about however A to Z multivitamin but I
think that's largely because lots of
people history I mean the quality of
them has been terrible historically but
also people take them as like a
they just think that what if I take this
I don't have to eat fruits and
vegetables I have to do anything else so
I'm ticking the box and actually that's
just not how it really works nice so
let's say I as an influencer decided to
show my own supplement yeah how does how
does one go about making a supplement so
you would go to a supplement
manufacturer and you would say can you I
want to put some stuff in a capsule and
sell it to people and they would go okay
what do you want to put in and you might
say well I think maybe a bit of this and
a bit of that and they would say all
right well why don't you also put this
in and this in because they've got some
of that on the shelves and they go how
about this a bit this and a bit of that
and then they put a load of like
horrible stuff in there anti-caking
agents and all kinds of other things you
don't really want to be putting in your
body and then your pills made and off
you go oh and so if I were to be like
let's let's add a stamp of kind of
credibility on this let's consult a
qualified dietitian and a nutritionist
or if I continue and was like hey Sophie
can you help me make a supplement yeah
would you just be like all right this is
the list of ingredients you want to give
to the manufacturer so we would go okay
who's it for what's the target group
what are we looking for what effect are
we trying to have for people what are we
what's the outcome that we want people
to say or feel what are we trying to aim
for who are we trying to sell it to
who's your target market what are they
doing what's their lifestyle like what
foods are they likely to be eating or
not eating like what does their diet
look like roughly on average so that we
can see what people are eating enough of
and what they're not eating enough of so
they might need a little bit more of
this and a bit less of this and then we
would say okay these are the things that
we think are really important and then
we go all right we can't fit all of that
in so let's adjust what we first will
look at all the research we look at the
papers in terms of how much of a B
vitamin makes an impact on this for
example then we go okay what can we fit
in a capsule do you want to be two
capsules or one capsule what size
capsule is right for your Market is it
people that are going to complain about
it being too big in which case we need
to go down and are we gonna have three a
day or two a day what's right for you
right all this stuff to think about how
much can we fit in what's going to go in
there what's the price point would you
want to sell it at because some of the
ingredients that I like to use are
really expensive because they work
really well so it's kind of all of these
puzzle pieces that we put in and so that
whole bit of conversation is clearly a
lot longer than you going to manufacture
and just saying can you put this in a
capsule please right so there's a lot
more to think about if you're making
things properly and thoughtfully and
trying to have an impact like we've done
with Heights so it is a much more
complicated process takes a lot of time
but then I come up with a formula which
then goes to the manufacturer for
pricing and kind of whether they can fit
it in a capsule some things take up more
space than other things so you're moving
things around a little bit but that's
basically the process of getting it to
manufacture with a nutrition
professional nice and so you've been
helping to well you formulate Heights
Heights and also the smart probiotic
yeah how did that process work so
probiotics it turns out really difficult
to make so arguably more complicated
than the smart supplement even though
the smart supplements look super
complicated so probiotics are fussy so
you have to be really careful with the
environment that they're produced in you
have to use it's much better to use what
we call proprietary strains so there'll
be a few there's a few really good
probiotic manufacturers across Europe
I'm talking about literally maybe five
and they have their own proprietary
strains that all have research on them
so they'll have done specific research
on their specific strains which is
important because all the different
bacteria are genetically slightly
different so you might grow one in here
and it's a bit genetically different to
this one but it might have the same name
so you want to get it from the people
who've done the actual research on it so
that happens then you have to say well
can we put these five different strains
from your strain Bank in combination and
they might say well no because that one
fights with that one and they don't get
on and then they end up killing each
other off and then you say okay well
this is how long we want to get so the
sooner you get probiotics people the
better because if it sits on shelves
every day that's on the Shelf it's
losing probiotic count right so some of
the ones that you pick up from the back
of a Shelf at a pro at a health food
store they've been sat there for two
years there's not gonna be anything left
in there realistically then you have to
think about the capsule so we want to
make sure it's getting to your colon and
not being released in the stomach or in
the small bowel because if it gets worse
in the stomach too much then the acid
kills off the probiotic bacteria so
you've got to try and make sure it gets
to the place where it survives and does
its job so it's like a really
complicated process and also things like
so with vitamins now I'm like familiar
with that and I'll say Okay I want this
much B vitamin and then I want that much
of a probiotic but they're like it's
really fluffy and it takes up loads of
space and I'm like but I don't
understand why and there's no that's not
for me if you can explain to me why I
can't have something I can work around
it but it was like with that formula
it's like here's what we want and they
come back so I can't do that and I'm
like but why and they can't really
properly explain why because it's just
like a manufacturing thing like it's
like a that one's too fluffy or it
doesn't work with this one or whatever
it is I'm it was complicated it took us
two years to make that but I'm super
proud of it and the results have been
amazing and we just as I said just doing
the human trials with it now and
listening to everyone's feedback and
it's been really positive so what's in
this this is like a capsule with like
powder and yeah so seven strains of
probiotic bacteria in there okay yeah so
just like a lot of bacteria yeah so like
loads and loads of bacteria
and bacteria looks like powder yeah yeah
really oh yeah so it's freeze-dried uh
it's freeze I don't know how to make it
work to be honest so it's basically
loads and loads of probiotic bacteria
that are dried and then they are all
coated so micro encapsulated and that
means that they can survive in your GI
tract as carefully as possible
so the capsule is the capsule keeps them
alive but they are also the powder
itself is also micro encapsulated to
help survivability even further oh
that's healthy and so what's the benefit
of taking one of these so there's
amazing data on probiotics in terms of
so that one in particular the strains we
focused on are gut brain access stuff so
making sure that your gut and your brain
are communicating effectively not over
communicating but also these studies
that we talked about about anxiety and
depression and cortisol levels reducing
cortisol levels managing those kinds of
things we've also got some amazing
strains for General gut health in there
so you mentioned that you noticed your
poo consistency had changed and was more
consistent when you were taking it and
that's feed like feedback that we've had
from lots of our early customers is that
if they had slightly too loose stalls
before it was firmer and if there's two
stalls were too hard before it's more
loose so it's a better consistency for
them so consistency of stool is there
there's lots of stuff around General gut
health but also immunity and
inflammation so we think the
inflammation is really really key to
lots of these conditions that we've
talked about today so we've kind of
focused really specifically on the
strains that we know to have the effects
that they want them to have which is
borne out in kind of all of everything
that we do for Heights what you find
with other probiotic products
most of them were designed for animals
and they've just randomly come across a
formula that they can see has some
benefits in humans
but you know probiotic research has
moved on and we can be really specific
and targeted about what we're looking
for now and I can see a world in the
future where someone goes all right
here's my probiotic for immunity here's
my probiotic for my gut brain axis
here's my probiotic for this and they
have a sort of piecing together of the
different probiotic strains that they
want to use rather than this kind of
here's your gut health supplement type
picture
would it be true that in an in an
absolutely Ideal World if someone was
getting all of their like having a super
healthy diet and stuff they wouldn't
need to take any supplements or
probiotics or is there like additional
Alpha to be had by actually taking one
of these yeah well so what we know to be
true is that if you are able to eat
perfectly every single day all the
things we've talked about already making
sure the diet's perfectly balanced all
the time drinking plenty of water you're
not drinking alcohol you're not drinking
too much tea and coffee caffeine
depletes this blah blah you're not
stressed your life is ideal and you're
super Zen uh then probably you don't
need a supplement right but the reality
is most of us are rushing around we're
eating meal to meal we're not thinking
too much about it we don't want to think
too much about it we are eating
croissants for breakfast instead of the
things that we know to be better for us
all this kind of stuff is happening and
we're stressed which depletes our
nutrients and we are living in a
polluted environment which means we're
using up more antioxidants and our food
is depleted in nutrients and we are and
and and and we're having too much coffee
alcohol these things that deplete every
thing and so in reality modern living
means that nutritional supplements
vitamin supplements can be really
beneficial for lots of people with
probiotics
we evolved in our microbiome evolved in
an environment where we lived much more
closely with the Earth where we were
growing our own vegetables and picking
things from the ground and living much
more closely with animals you know pigs
sheep that kind of stuff and we were our
microbiome was much much more diverse we
ate seasonally so we ate different
things naturally we ate a lot more
fermented foods because it was a good
way of preserving things we had a very
different diet and lifestyle to what
we've evolved to now which is like a
western type lifestyle where our
microbiome population is really really
different to what it was maybe even 50
years ago certainly a hundred years ago
and if we come compare a western
microbiome to someone who lives in rural
Africa or rural China we can see ours is
just so inferior in so many ways and you
know people within that field would say
that's why we're suffering with diabetes
cardiovascular disease depression
anxiety because our microbiome is so
affected and if we add into that the way
that we eat now
but also the fact that many of us would
have had lots of antibiotics growing up
which just kill off your microbiome we
also
um do all sorts of things as an impact
we're more stress all that kind of stuff
we we disinfect everything we've spent
however many years doing this hand gel
stuff now all of these things were
careful with disinfectant everything
else all these things impact our
microbiome preservatives and food
emulsifies and food all that stuff and
now we're in a situation where actually
our microbiomes are kind of just not
doing as good a job as they could do so
introducing more probiotic strains
especially some of these kind of less
commonly found microbial strange
bacterial strains can obviously reseed
our microbiome with lots of these
beneficial things that we need and these
impacts that they're having on us so you
know ideally we will eat beautifully and
perfectly all the time and we go out
into nature all the time we're hugging
trees and we're kissing trees and
touching the ground and all that kind of
stuff and introducing bacteria but in
reality that's not the world we live in
so I think we have to take a pragmatic
look at that and think about what our
bodies need given the lifestyles that we
lead what's the what is the business of
being a dietitian look like if someone's
listening to this and they're thinking
you know what this dietitian thing
sounds that sounds interesting would you
recommend it as a career and then I
guess what does the I guess building
your own business off the back end look
like as well yeah I mean it's a
fantastic career you can do I mean I've
done so many different things within
dietetics and you can do so many
different things and in theory if I got
bored of talking about the gut which I
never will but if I did get one of that
tomorrow I could go and do some work and
become a diabetes dietitian you know I'd
have to do some go back to a basic level
and train again but you know I could go
and learn about and completely do have a
pivot you know so there's so many
different things available and now is a
great time to get into it because
you know everyone's talking about it
it's everywhere and it's becoming more
and more important and more and more
well recognized which is amazing as a
profession
um one of the things that's super
important to remember is that you do a
three or four year degree or you do a
two year Masters then you need to go
into the NHS and learn how to do your
job right so people young people now say
to me I just want to do what you do and
I'm like I'm 15 years deep in my career
right I've been doing this for a long
time that eight years in the NHS five
years in Academia now I do what I do and
like you have got to do like you've got
to do that time because every patient
that you see in the NHS every
colleague's connection that you make is
a bit like driving a car you do when you
pass your driving tests after that you
come across all the different things
that you need to learn about and what
you need to bring to your practice if
you as a new newly qualified dietitian
start trying to see patients in private
practice you're going to do them a
massive disservice because you just
don't know enough right and people are
paying you and they're going to be
really disappointed and they're going to
go away and they're going to say sorry
dietitian but should just tell me to eat
more vegetables and drink more water
because that's all you know about right
so you have to do your time you have to
pay your pages they say 10 000 hours
don't they that makes you an expert in
something and I think that probably
stands to reason with dietetics as well
I have no idea how many years that is
but I think you've got to go and learn
on the job realistically in and you know
in the UK we're so lucky to have the NHS
as a learning facility like you can
learn everything you need to know from
everything in the NHS is incredible and
most countries would just killed to have
that opportunity so as a dietitian it's
really important to go and learn your
craft find out which area you're really
interested in get really passionate
about it because otherwise you're going
to end up talking about something you
don't care about and hopefully it really
comes across how much I'm interested and
care about what I do because it makes a
difference to your everyday life
so it's really important page using that
way then so it's a business uh it works
so the way that my business running in
lots of different ways but the way that
my business runs is the dietitians that
work for me they mostly all still work
in the NHS or work in other words or
working research but they will do a
profit split situation so we have a
ratio that they they take and I take so
we attract all the patients and we do
the promotion of everybody and we
maintain the website we have a full
admin Team all that kind of stuff the
dietitians will come and see their
patients and they take a cut of what we
take from them so they have a favorable
cut compared to other Clinics of what we
take and that business like
is I love it I'm really passionate about
it because I really want to bring really
great evidence-based nutrition to people
who have medical conditions because
otherwise they see people and get
completely messed up and go in the wrong
direction but it's not necessarily a
hugely profitable business it's great I
love it I love seeing patients and I
will always do it but it's not
necessarily hugely profitable because
you're just working on this profit split
situation so I would say that the
dietitians who work
for me basically cover the admin and
cover the costs and then I take the
profit of the patients that I see
essentially which is fine works well for
me
then the consultancy is much easier way
of having consistent Revenue so for
dietitians listening or someone who's
thinking about this is listening doing
having Clinic income and just to be
clear I only work in clinic two days a
week so I'm always physically present
and from a CEO perspective always
present to run that business but like in
terms of clinic hours I do two days a
week in clinic then the other three days
a week I do consultancy and having
consultancy income is super super
helpful and important because it's
consistent and it means that you know
what you're getting whereas particularly
when you're building up your clinic
business you are going to end up with
maybe three patients one week and no
patience the next week and that's just
not something you could live on
so it takes time to build that up and
now I'm fully booked until May because
of the show which is amazing but also
just a bit overwhelming so uh yeah so
you need a bit of everything and keeping
your fingers in pies is really important
and now kind of adding more of the media
stuff in is really helpful so it's about
having those multiple income streams I
think but really importantly I think it
really helps for them all to be on the
same thread because I spend a lot of
time trying to do some Social Media
stuff the more Social Media stuff I do
gets people into clinic so if I was on
social media talking about diabetes but
I only see gut health patients it's not
going to work is it so talk about gut
health on there that feeds into there
all my time is kind of you know on the
TV talking about that Health that feeds
into clinic and it all works
in synchrony as opposed to it being kind
of all over the place the power of
having a niche yeah exactly yeah we talk
about the love for like YouTube channels
and businesses and stuff yeah yeah I
guess even in the business I mean it's a
business right like your personal brand
is as the gut person yeah I mean it is a
virtual cycle yeah I never thought it
would be but this is what I'm doing yeah
um final question how how did you end up
on TV what was the story there so I've
always done a little well since I was at
Kings I've done a little bit of TV work
here and there mainly kind of you know
on the one show where they go let's go
and talk to our expert Sophie about this
particular thing so we got off and I've
done kind of inside the factory and uh
how to lose weight well this kind of
magaziney type diet shows that sort of
thing so I've done a fair bit of that
done a bit of live TV and then my lovely
friends Alana and Lisa who run a company
called the gut stuff had been pitching
this show to channel four or what all to
production companies for ages
um about trying to bring gut health to
the general population get people to
understand a bit more about it
and they finally got commissioned by the
production company monkey and channel 4
took it which we filmed a pilot I was
obviously screen tested but these are
the kind of my friends so it was really
what we wanted to work together screen
tested help them to kind of develop the
format a little bit and then in terms of
doing a bit more clinical stuff then
perhaps I think about doing before
and then we filmed it so Channel 4
commissioned it and we filmed it over
the summer last year it's kind of the
process nice yeah it's been amazing and
so far it's like doing Clinic book with
all my mates right
like do people like recognize you on the
street now or like how do you know what
I was so worried this is embarrassing
story I was so worried about being
recognized and I was saying to my agent
like wait who I got after I got the show
I'm so worried about this I'm quite a
shy person naturally like when I'm
talking about work I'm fine but when I'm
on my own I'm like always with my dog
looking like [__] and like I don't want
people to be like oh that woman who
talks about poo on the TV the only
person who's recognized me so far is the
pest control man that was outside my
house visiting a neighbor
so it's fine yeah for sure but you know
what's really nice is I I suspect that
people are recognizing me because I've
heard a few conversations near me about
the show and people saying have you seen
that show on Channel 4 and stuff like
that so maybe people are I guess what
I'm doing is not I'm not on love Island
right as well I'm not having to people
aren't no one's fangirling me they're
just like oh that's interesting yeah I
think that's her which is a nice it's a
nice way of doing things for sure
um any so for someone who's listened to
the end of this very long conversation I
think it's been like two and a half
hours sorry I'm super into the gut stuff
they're like I really want to find out
more what are some recommended resources
that you can point people in the
direction of listen um the psychobiotic
if you're interested in psychobiotics
psychobotic Revolution John cryan is an
amazing place to start it's really
accessible and so super super
interesting
um the gut stuff who are part of the TV
show they um have amazing resources on
their website in terms of gut health and
things like that we've got loads of
blogs on our website which is City
dietitians.co.uk the girls who run our
social media channels at citydartitions
we've got loads of really interesting
information coming up all the time on
there they do an amazing job of running
that and obviously I'm on social media
at Sophie dietitian lots of stuff on
there that people can pick up but
there's yeah always sharing stuff so
people can come along and find out
fantastic Sophie thank you so much it
has been wonderful pleasure thank you
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye